all right darlings are we live you know
what to do
tell us
if we are live let us know if we're live
and tell us how messed up our microphone
sound quality is
can't get the sound going right until
you guys yeah
you guys are
ours like sound crew yes
all right hey what's up scotty what a
new scotty we just watched the final
episode of stranger things
gotta prep the next three and four for
tomorrow
my brother said he wanted to stop by
coy's at star wars celebration
awesome good old koi jean-drew please
stop letting that guy talk so much on
your show
oh
never ever never ever ever never left
the chat in front of us so we can see
thank you guys so much how's it going oh
zach stone is gonna be famous oh thank
you guys for popping on in here this
means a lot thanks for the super chat
there kenneth if we get it blow the chat
down i'm kind of surprised by how many
people are here right telling john
before i'm like dude there's not gonna
be a lot of people it's 8 30 at night
for us
30 on a saturday i'm like there's not
gonna be anyone here so the fact that we
have just you guys here right now that
means a lot thank you yeah look at all
you there's it's going faster than that
ryder let me just olivia
like do i know you comment below i know
ann olivia has a little instagram story
daniel's heroine aditya raj
this is chaos i'm in the middle of
moving if you follow me on instagram
we're in the middle of moving just got a
place
and uh
it's it's so
it's it's a little chaotic for us behind
the scenes so this is the audio john
find out if the audio sounds okay while
i do this hey guys
do me a favor while i connect my
bluetooth
are we audible and uh oh dang here since
400k that's crazy thank you thank you
not bad it's 10 30 there well i i'm glad
that you're staying up late with us on a
saturday night 11
30. dizzle one million fellow rejects
joseph lapillio
yeah ben john doing my thing making
thank you for oh i really thought
there'd be like no one in here i really
i was telling john
no one would care i was telling him like
i really don't think there's gonna be
many people here so like let's not
stress and just make it really loose and
you guys are here right now thank you
um i'm just going to get you all heavy
spoilers is messaging me
and he hasn't said congratulations you
dick i hope you're watching paul
paul that's the real why no call paul
huh ending explained paul's a [ __ ] damn
guys thank you guys so much um audio
sounds good you did good this time
awesome thank you jack greenway thank
you for being here so much oh i got much
of a super chat thank you guys
oh my goodness
our first subscriber
and uh wow there's a lot of comments
all right so here's what i'm going to do
we care craig we care
uh jaby will be here he's going to swing
by oh the audio does sound good hey what
do you know that's a that's an
unexpected accomplishment oh right off
the bat
we're getting better at this um okay so
a few things that i wanted to thank
obviously john for being on this i don't
know this whole time
uh with me
when uh with this channel went in a
different direction around the 500k mark
is when i feel like this channel became
the best it could be although we were
watching some of the ryan wright videos
back in the day this is my solo reviews
and that [ __ ] was hilarious i get
cancelled like a [ __ ] oh i love
them you guys ever want to just clip
that out get us under a million
subscribers again
i sit around and hope for the return of
straight to the point i really do god i
came out
it's like i'm not really this guy yeah
i'm not really this perverted so for
those who are with us before then and
then now that uh that means a lot and um
i want to thank koi for being part of
the team now
i'm going to tell you guys right now uh
if you guys remember sally the monaco
salamander sally uh we're working on
something with her or she hasn't seen
most of the marvel movies and she's only
seen a few of them like once
and so i was like why don't you do all
the phase one through four reactions for
us so she's gonna be doing that for us
so we've been sending her equipment
because she lives in new york i wanna
thank uh the people at prepper
for helping us do all this editing uh
because we wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for them i wanna thank my brother for
all the help that he's given along the
way every guest that we've ever had on
this channel
back when i was living in like what is
essentially a studio apartment way back
in the day you know like dan alyssa i
should probably tell we're live uh
lauren jeremy shine i'm just thinking of
random names maria
um and uh my fiance olivia especially
for supporting me like a [ __ ]
lately
uh john
who else have we gotten eric nerd
chronic
um
our brand guy tom oh tom he's got the
greatest i got a house and we're hiring
people to do s
seconds here on the channel for us guys
so expect a few more brand deals from
now on because we got to pay these
people so yeah um yeah so that a lot of
them
we are the chan when we say that like
the brands are going to help support and
produce content we really mean that
because like we're hiring coy and we're
hiring sally
and um
god uh i'm sure i'll think of some other
people along the way yeah air and gordon
aaron alexander there's a lot of people
and you guys especially you guys for
being here this whole time thank you um
for for if you're new or if you've been
here for years thank you guys so much
tara erickson cat alvarado cat alvarado
amy castle lauren francesca
julia wendy lee
thompson heavy spoilers paul philip
molina's been a big help too oh yeah
everyone thank you guys
uh thank you so much but now let's uh
let's let's talk in the comments round
on and whoever i didn't think uh you
clearly didn't mean enough to know
i didn't think well uh uh the popular
man i'll say it back h4 [ __ ] but we we
can hit
more billion all right more the morbius
uh lives lives here by the way i think
if you haven't read the description box
you should especially if tyrone magnus
is here yes thank you tyrone
along the way too you should read the
description box tyrion magnus
uh but let me share this john let's kick
off some questions what are we saying in
the live stream guys what john has said
it's this is going to be chaotic if you
already thought our live streams were a
mess
especially a mess today i've been i've
been doing adjustments to make it so
that we can actually read the live chat
it's going by so fast
you guys are saying the nicest things in
the chat right now thank you
zentorno says just remember your tasm 2
trailer reaction was in the first
reaction vids i've ever seen three
spidey films later here we are been here
since 100k wow you guys are being so
nice j lefrey robot dance i think the
channel is better than it's ever been to
be totally frank guys because
you know it's it's this when this
channel started growing it was mainly me
on a on a laptop okay you remember that
oh yeah i have guests come by all the
time which is me on a laptop and then to
think about where it is now
and then you know like we i used to just
like dump six videos a day
but like just jump cuts and now the
point that we're at uh you know with the
work we've been able to do i think that
i think the videos are better than they
were
six years ago yes they've grown they're
they're much better now
i think especially now um yeah i'm
really proud of what the channel is and
and i i do feel like i'm proud of it and
thank you guys for supporting us along
the way john keeping up some stuff my
brother might be here yeah i got to
bring him and then
the new and then we'll get to all all
the rest of your lovely inputs uh you're
in the house so new neil i've been
watching you guys since 2017 or
something it's so good to see you guys
grow so much congrats thank you so new
neil appreciate you very much
here since 400 k koi is goaded for sure
he is one of the greatest
um and thank you lilith damon you are
hotter than the both of us combined uh i
just thought i should throw that out
there but we do appreciate being uh
reassured of our of our uh you know
visuals
damn 12. so how old are you how old are
you now you're about to be 18 pretty
soon so you've been watching for six odd
years damn
well i'm glad that we could guide you
like two
uh you know very responsible and uh you
know conscientious older brothers i'd
like to think that a lot of your
accomplishments could be credited
directly to us or indirectly to any way
that it gets back here and we could take
credit
it's good for me
missing tooth gang jessica cowan how's
it going from patreon right yeah it's
good to see you
missing tooth game if we hit 2 million
i'll explain the story of my tooth
that's the deal i'm making today and i'm
sticking with it
so you know help us get to two billion
subscribers and i will explain my pirate
uh appearance
too drunk to drive there koi
everybody dog pile on koi in the chat
all right
jack greenway had the audio perfect i'm
screenshotting that comment just just
love it appreciate that uh now i'm gonna
i'm gonna pin coy to the wall of shame
right now because coy is too drunk to
drive here i want everybody to go
and subscribe to koi's channel so you
can be rate coy
for not joining us in our in our moment
of celebration because clearly koi
doesn't give two [ __ ] that's not true
koi is it star wars celebration
when he could be at the real rejects
celebration
the beast says
i remember your drive review
that's not coy
rachel model and you just kept talking
about how much you would suck his dick
that is a classic review
jabus coabus is in the i'm in the middle
of chaos koi guys koi's here on the
phone
say hi koi you are fired up antonius
let's check your levs bro talking over
koi you guys are talking over toy and
he's on the phone everyone okay go ahead
koi
now's a good time
say what you got to say
is not easy
we're figuring this out all right buddy
we gotta go but thank you bud i love you
man
congratulations on the homeownership
yeah thanks
we'll talk soon man hi rachel now he's
at celebration
you know how coy is and a girl's house
boy is drunk at a girl's celebration
is there alcohol here as well
damn you should have been
all right let's go back to the live
stream you should have been here when we
recorded obi-wan and had all this
alcohol on hand we planned to drink and
didn't
i literally you should have i had things
but i don't have them now
melanie
yeah oh somebody was just talking about
yeah i remember you your drive review
you just kept talking about how much you
would suck his dick see people remember
the ryan got the ryan right days
totally suck
i want it back
i absolutely want that bag mr duff says
talk about that in the netflix uh
trailer review no no no no yes we did
how do we adjust for this frame john
because we got
we got we got we got we're all over the
place all right um
let's just all get back
this autofocus is killing us
yes you should
you have a smaller chair i got an idea i
got an idea to make this work guys all
right this this live stream is going to
be chaotic switching as we said
as we said hold on switch you switching
lenses oh you're working with a sony
that's right man john get out of there
we're going oh shazbot hold the stream
down okay javascript how do i move this
you don't need to see all right you just
need to sense it because it's rejects
into phase two all right one billion
morbius just made four billion dollars
there we go congrats a millie a millie a
millie
a millie a millionaire
a millionaire over here for a second all
right
dude we should get over here all right
there's a reason these chairs have no
arms so now i have two microphones now
you go to the center
now you're probably deafening people
with feedback
when you said your name was greg i felt
lied to oh dude
[Laughter]
hey we're here yes we're doing this yeah
that was true that was traumatic for
certain people when you came out when
you came out as yourself i told you to
be hot congrats greg and john why would
grace randolph be loving this so
the real rejects just hit a million
subscribers
but where it is
i hear grace is actually a really
pleasant person in real life
so the real rejects
apparently you think grace is some
british man so the real rejects
there's trouble on set of the real
rejects because greg doesn't want to
wear the hair
you know what i meant or it was for uh
the fast and furious option shot thing
yeah she's like we should take a photo
i'm like
i didn't even realize it was her
initially where's the chara
she's eating her eyes with the ice cream
character come in here
strategy hd you guys you guys cheer you
guys inspire me to start my own channel
thank you for the love inspiration and
content you guys put out absolutely well
deserved and keep it up thank you and
hey good luck keep keep on chugging
villains guys this is an open q a ask
questions so we know what to talk about
ask queues uh a real reject set up you
have a table that like we have a whole
what you are so
we literally were in stream labs being
like how do we fix this bar here i have
uh
the place i got um there's gonna be a
new office in there and we're gonna have
a whole new setup and a different
background we're not gonna go like oh
we're reinventing the studio it's really
gonna be we're just migrating everything
you see here this is gonna be slightly
up the quality of these things is gonna
be better that's the number one goal is
to make that better first and foremost
and a table to cover the stomachs all
right i'm gonna read your guys's stream
from the phone that way i could just
read off questions from there achara may
have my phone please
achara bring the phone
bring me my communicator away can you
turn jaby's mic on
oh
yeah don't that's not why i'm here to
read the comments i am on record that's
not my fault right
that's your fault i turned it on when i
handed it to you
i turned it on when i handed it to you
jabez coabus there's no excuse
hey koi nice to see you man villains
says congrats greg and john y'all are
such a huge inspiration to me in my
channel happy to see y'all finally reach
this milestone and to quote someone we
all know
10 million
subscribers taking that away from you
more billion yes more be a sweep
oh on the camera
just off screen
you don't even realize we just watched
the finale of stranger things yeah and
we're going to tell you all about what
we just sat there like two and a half
hours we filmed for three hours and
we're like oh we're about to hit i was
literally recording like we're two
subscribers away from a million maybe we
should maybe we should do a live stream
and then
now i'm like oh this is so disorganized
this is the issue with younger brothers
they never believe you they never
believe you i was like greg you're gonna
hit a million today he's like no i'm not
that's not gonna happen there's no way
it's not sorry you can see here uh this
awkward blur
fine dude here's one though aaron
coleman wants to know what is y'all's
favorite real rejects skit ooh
i think my favorite real reject skit the
one where he doesn't talk about his dick
is uh there are many
i think i think my favorite one
do you have one john
fave we have we don't do skits too often
because they take one
that's not that
one was cool maybe maybe mission
impossible the mission impossible was
the hardest one to do yeah that was
definitely the hardest one it was very
rewarding once it was complete stopping
john from leaving uh now i like that one
but it's not my favorite yeah maybe the
batman i mean the batman batman is the
coolest fighter i like the best i don't
remember the batman one when i punched
john yeah we did the punch i punched
john in many sketches
i get punched a lot yeah and i deserve
it each time
okay i'm not going to bother you
explaining it to me i don't remember it
that's all right i don't remember
anything you do most of them start with
me being late to a trailer
i just follow i'll just follow the amber
her trial directly instead of watching
your reactions to it alexander tristan
asks what is uh most memorable video
what do you think oh god i don't know
there's like 18 000 videos on this
channel i have no idea being hit with a
uh what do you call it um a poll uh when
did you first start watching the channel
back in the og
reasons to see days yeah reasons to see
our original review show
where we give you reasons to see and not
just been watching since you were
smoking in a sly cooper used to smoke
cigarettes
[Music]
yeah that was a while ago first real
rejects reaction was for the godzilla
2014 teaser with greg thanks for the
amazing journey guys that's from linda
productions i actually remember when i
did that reaction that's when people
were like where's this who is this guy
where's he
still
yeah fix jaby's mic
he needs to make the live stream all
about him and if we don't get there as
soon as possible we are [ __ ]
everywhere
wow hello
did john do it
is it working now lighthammer 66 showing
support 50 bucks
really thanks and
oh yeah we got super chess we'll we will
get to when did you all know this
youtube actually was actually a
potential job
uh
oh god um
i realized that once greg started making
money
i think um i was i i just wanted us to
break into doing like just movie reviews
i didn't think you could actually make
money
and then i
bought a stupid jacket and then i
remember there was uh or the only one in
this chat fixated on your crush
and then there was like
and then and then one day i was like
someone i realized like oh there's this
thing you have to turn on after a year
of uploading videos you have to turn
adsense on
and i turn it on
and then i was like
and then we made 57 cents and i was like
you can make money doing this and
that's when i started going gung-ho
where i was doing working i started
doing the job yeah dude you're in the
past my guy
full-time job and then i had uh then i
was coming back in between shifts and
and nighttime to go uh film for the
channel that's what i would do
apparently it's working this low
all right i'm gonna self-absorb this
guys he's just all about himself all
about the whole time all right tess
shows up it's like make sure i'm i'm i'm
the best let me make sure i'm gonna say
i'm sorry nice job guys been watching
since the good wanda vision days awesome
to see that's way way back not like the
shitty one of them yeah man i remember
that
tribal yt wants to know where is ryan
right right right is cancelled right is
locked in a box right right is the
threat you know that chat is a few
seconds behind like 30 seconds behind
here's one so every time you mess with
it turning it off and on you might be
turning it on when you're when you're
being told it might be turning off when
you're like they're saying japanese
microsoft i'm turning this off i think
you're reacting too much in real time to
it
dude movie reaction in a theater would
be very fun uh but uh here's a question
when greg met john
uh third grade third grade we sat in
those uh
square desks yeah they put four desks
facing each other yeah where it's like
really inconvenient for like kids who
have to like look over their shoulder to
like look at the whiteboard yeah push
this 48 volts sure you got this you know
jaby just do whatever you want
does it working now just mess with our
audio with that elevator is it working
now you guys we're going to get to the
point where he's going to turn our
volume all the way down where is jeff
it's going to be at 100 percent nicholas
prasad
you said 30 seconds no it's fine
nicholas prasad wants to know where jeff
is but i think
i'm trying to address where my old
persona went okay
no we can talk about you i love talking
about jaby kawai it's just funny how
like jerry was just john chris
chris boston says greg first hooked me
to the real rejects with just two words
as he reviewed content nipple nipple
chills hey man my phrase we're working
on some new shirts guys you're gonna be
excited about that just some introverted
human uh greg is gonna do a reaction to
everything everywhere all at once and
i'm very excited i am excited to be i
would love to be there for that i i'm
sad i can't be in it i'll be there i'll
do it i'd rather you not distract me
while i'm doing my first time watching
i'll just talk about me the whole time
here's my thoughts and opinions here's
what's coming up that i'm looking
forward to when i saw this the first
time let me tell you
i probably just sit quiet and look at
you the whole time you like this part do
you like it yeah don't be like stop i
feel i don't want
our taco 71 nipple chills is just so
iconic thank you
yes greg just some of your teeth check
your teeth bruh i got chocolate on my
teeth philly cheese wants to know why
north man wasn't covered uh we just we
didn't have the time that week and then
if we're a week late they become
irrelevant on our channel it's the way
it works with our views yeah maybe
unfortunately maybe we'll do a reaction
if we can find a way not to get it
blocked for incredibly gory content but
i was we were thinking about doing a
reaction we were like if we get a a
because the odds are we get like a you
know flagged for like a yellow dollar
bill so i was like if we got a brand new
man escaped
yeah
i remember the salamander sally and
elizabeth crazy days shawn williams
sound manager sally days are coming back
yeah uh as like i said to begin this
stream doing something with sally and uh
i'll call this uh to see if she wants to
come over andrew
um what's up oh no i was
but yeah it would be great dude we
should we got how many super chats do we
have we got too many super chats i have
to prep the stranger things episode
three and four reactions so
i always say this every stream we can't
be live for too long they end up being
live for like four hours so uh yeah
while we read some of the super chats
yeah thank you guys for
everyone who's here thank you guys so
much for being here last one see my ice
pack last one before we jump over andrew
a hint says love some of your random
reactions history of the world for
example your trailer reactions and so on
love it so proud boys thank you that was
a cool one that was uh it's mainly more
algorithm-based is the way we've had to
like maneuver the channel around lately
how's my volume oh my god
jaby kawaii speaking
oh there it is i can see it now yeah
look you're peaking you didn't need to
turn it up just then did you wow yes
let's go to the super chat window people
are lying that's what's happening you
got trolls in the chest confusing me
going his volume was fine and now it's
been
the past test test okay it's working
it's the past what is what is your
number why does greg and jaby have
different names that's a jaby question
no that's that's your fault that's what
happened so greg greg had a different
name before and it was ryan wright and i
was like i can do that i'll be jaby koey
and then and then
greg had a breakdown one day and he's
like you know what i'm going to be greg
i'm like [ __ ] ugh i went all this
time coming up with that i've got a
thousand subscribers i can't change it
now i just can't tell you my name it's
too late i've got a thousand subscribers
i'm committed to this direction that's
why
but you know you got to work hard people
it doesn't matter if you have a million
subs
it's about putting the work in you know
what i mean
you're still getting crap are you doing
cronk what are you doing no i don't know
oh cronk what's cronk i think cronk is
from the dead emperor's yeah
he sounded like no one ever references
croc i thought that's what you were
saying
or he's a wheelchair guy from family guy
as well there's a disney joint i haven't
seen emperor's new group that's good and
i also haven't seen that movie went
through hell i just learned the other
day there's a youtube channel we should
talk about instead of yours
either um it was a [ __ ] show did you
ever see that youtube channel guys i'm
gonna have chris wrap i'm gonna have
your live stream chat on my phone here i
got it here too chris ralph hey pandemic
jones it says jaby's mic it's still not
working can you turn jaby's mic up i
think your mic's not working test it it
shows us working there christ jesus we
don't know man uh yeah it's working oh
my god cody leach watches us i watched
your dexter reviews
no way really is that the same cody
leech
could be probably oh damn i literally
watched your for dexter new blood i
didn't know that
cool nice
achara
can you check if my mic is working on
the live stream
i i let me do it all right
john doesn't like hey chris ralph first
uh super chat of the day i don't know
why you wound up in the batman section
it's his mic it says it's working it
says it's working you guys are all right
i don't know
we'll find out review
okay aaron okay
says the mic is fine
and then dead channel says mike is
working good did you do improv because i
don't think you know how to listen to a
group of people when they're talking
this is what i do for you you beat the
guy changing the scene oh it's michael
scott going i have a gun in my place
yeah i'm just changing it all the time
like this is not how it
goes there's a gun in my pocket
that's an office reference for those of
you that don't know
uh the mic is working seen top gun
did you like top gun you'd like to
according to your thumbnail you like top
gun i love top gun
what's up john nothing no talk i'm
listening to the audio now continuously
oh good how is it how's it sound
your mic is on
we got this okay
guys let's read some of these chats i
got your chat right here on my phone one
day we'll learn how to live stream the
way jaby does all right which is just
change the conversation out of what a
woman's noticing
that's how you keep them on their toes
what are they talking about right now we
don't know your favorite review thank
you for the super chat chris roth
favorite review
favorite review phoenix uh says i have
chickens this is exactly what we
literally are doing at super chat oh
okay that's what i want to do
sorry i i appreciate chaos but pay a
little just a little a sin john's about
to snap at you i'm about to kill you
i've never seen i've never seen john
like this before honestly john angry is
the best that's when you're like that's
when you're like you know when you're
like bullying someone and then the the
bullied kid stands up to you and then
the bully's like oh no what have i done
oh whoa john's the guy on the side
john's the bullied joke
oh no i am weak now now that he has
stood up
um he towers
someone get coy and uber uh no he's at a
girl's place i'm pretty sure he'd rather
be there right now no i should get him
still all right let's read these some of
these super chats
chris ross thank you guys everyone who's
coming in the chat thank you all all
right a favorite review yeah okay hey
char char's in the background
move moved behind between them a little
bit so you're at least a little bit of a
blur
uh a favorite review morbius
i really liked my gravity review when it
was solo
not the one you're the ones with john uh
i liked i liked your review of uncharted
thanks i thought that was funny because
you were talking about how uh what's her
name took the thing from his backpack
and they never even made contact and
whatever like the way you made fun of
that at the theater was funny it makes
me feel good yeah john would you have a
favorite one of ours i think between you
with you and i i actually really liked
our top gun maverick review i loved that
i actually thought we did a really good
actually i was like this is pretty funny
yeah i thought that was a really even
though it's the most recent one but uh i
thought that was a pretty funny review i
refused to watch
that i'm just looking through the
playlist right now of all of our
different reviews i think fury of the
fist and the golden fleece is my
favorite
it's a big learning lesson [ __ ] that
movie
terrible learning lesson jordan garza is
asking how did you all feel about the
krasinski cgi that's not the next
question that is from doctor strange
yeah read the dates my diet what happens
this is how he does it pay attention to
the thumbnails
hold on which what's the order of the
super chats one day you'll learn what it
is to be able to i got it
they go down i'm trying to help you
go down
they start at the bottom and they go
upwards oh you're lucky these live
streams are never smooth or else or else
this would be a real problem yes um
what do we got here uh
okay stranger things two and three
uploaded tomorrow don't worry i'm gonna
get to your super chats life of nate
um
congrats on the one mill guys been with
you all since 2014 i know i recognize
your name also sidenote i'm drunk so
forgive me if i comment some gibberish
life of nate common gibberish away
we as as much as he's presenting on
organization he is completely anal about
organization when you go to his place so
i find it funny just how disruptive you
have made this stream so far when this
is not how
i don't think this would fly your stream
you know it's a pretty great i don't
know
[Laughter]
you know it's a pretty great review is
the call me by your name review that was
a great one and oh i like that one that
was on the toilet yeah and uh going back
to favorite sketches i don't know why it
didn't occur to me sooner but the the
saw sketch has always been a near and
dear to my heart that's a great one when
greg's balls get ripped off how are you
achara
yeah i did not like that we got counter
throughout i do not like all that work
you put into that did we get kenneth
radford jr as well no no no lucky seven
dollars per million subs more stranger
things please hashtag dance monkey dance
lamount ah thanks kenneth rathbun
thanks you so much spaceman you guys
have been a massive part of my life
since 200 000 subs thank you for
everything congrats i love you both so
much oh thank you space man means a lot
thank you spaceship man whoa light
hammer 66 just threw a 50 at us showing
support dude that is very early we can
now get coy for another video
donate to the koi this is the koi and
sally fun right now
so thank you guys
uh thank you lighthammer that's a really
generous contribution being jammin
cindellar yes my fellas congrats you
guys always make my day can't wait for
what's in store oh thank you thank you
you've been jamming cinderella
jaby's helped out a lot too we would
have not i mean we got a lot of help
with learning how to live stream camera
equipment
vol um audio i thought this was another
day this i didn't realize
he's helped us out tremendously with
knowing how certain things work on
youtube as well
and especially on the technical side
usually if we have a technical question
about anything operating system here
um
literally i wanted him to come over here
earlier so he could show us how to set
this up through obs
so he's actually been incredibly helpful
for the channel so he's not just here to
be here he's actually been a major
behind the scenes believe it or not guys
been a major major help and go watch
their amber heard videos
oh yeah
yes
gregor not only does he do text videos
he doesn't johnny depp hamburger video
yeah
greg will call me up and be like i need
help with this thing okay i gotta go now
bye yeah that's why i operate i'm always
on the go yeah
sometimes we ask you one question and
then it leads to a pandora's box of just
like oh my god where's an entire
workshop surrounding the just the area
of expertise involving your course it's
like you log on to netflix to watch one
thing and you're like oh there's so many
options now and i don't want to watch
anything
i've literally spent like two hours
writing an email for greg really
breaking down all the options yeah so no
i mean most of the time we ever see it
like when we got the new lens like
people were like that's a great new lens
he got that for us well it wasn't just
me it was achara mom and your sister
tara
you're all in the background
right achara
yeah she's got it she's fact-checking
she's got a charge that sits there i
don't know what char was it for was the
audio working when you checked
all right
let's keep going roberto studios john
take it away please let's go
the force is with you i still can't get
over kenobi making me feel things now
you reaching 1 million well earned i
remember being first introduced via
those reaction mash-ups and was
immediately drawn to your energy oh [ __ ]
those things pay off oh wow things pay
that's why we always sign those waivers
yes
20 bucks
roberto's been here of many times oh
that's crazy how that's actually the
first time i've ever heard of someone
being like i saw you in a compilation
decided to check you out and now we're
here that's actually have you ever had
that happen the lesson is always
overplay your emotions no always be
bigger than everybody else in the mashup
the lesson is don't worry that people
aren't going to watch your reaction
because now they've seen it in the
compilation
know that it could somehow circle back
to you i don't know that's ever happened
to me but i have been found i have found
myself in mashups thanks for voting last
door lance door our fire fighting
handsome man from canada he says about
damn time lol congrats guy boys
road to two million now what's going on
what's going on achara now it's hardest
contributing topper just wants to play
with my backpack oh gotcha
now we don't have food in there achara
we're trying to focus here there's not
food in that backpack
[ __ ] yeah so congrats boys learn to
listen
for my nonsense
green oxygen turned into a family
one million sorry i couldn't help with a
lot
no dude that's plenty you are every
million is built off once you guys don't
have to contribute to the live stream it
means a lot when you do but not i i feel
weird whenever someone's like sorry i
can't do enough just being we don't have
a limit here being one of the million is
enough thank you thank you for just
being here crazy dave 85. congrats been
watching you all for a long time jewel
says and your reactions to cobra car are
my favorite too thanks jules
uh mr
crazy dave85 thank you crazydave85 mr
random here um bro thank you for the
super chat i've been watching y'all
since i had two since i i had since you
all had 200k subs it's so amazing to see
others find you all as amazing as i see
you good job guys
not enough people buddy tyrone got there
a million subscribers ago yeah he's got
two million subscribers on his channel
now
so not enough people love us how many
plaques do you have that's why this
stream
is about being ungrateful for where
we're at jealousy and resentment where's
your all your plaques up there you
actually keep it out that's cool we got
an old school like you're proud of it
that's good yeah yeah when times are
down i stare at it like you're not
like you don't feel mocked by the
machine
i put mine under my bed oh we should
have achara read a question because
she's doing literally nothing
charm
hi
reed turtles oh turtle first you got to
thank them that's a that's oh sorry this
is called consideration you know show
some thanks i'm not very good at that um
thank you turtle for your very generous
five dollar super chat that's very nice
very good uh you deserve it
thanks for all the hard work the audio
sounds good that's right
thank you that's why he's super chat to
be like they need to shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
every time i hear sarah campbell i go
sarah
sarah campbell you know that's you know
what we're doing you know jonathan are
doing total recall no no no
no
you're getting warmer no it's from get
gunther
that's from the last action hero
yes expendables three jpq's the filipino
commercials we got to bring back thanks
for bringing that up jolly i will
acknowledge a random comment here in
between every super chat thank you hey
i usually get harangued for doing this
yeah don't worry i got you on my phone
for a reason jpq stevens let's jabby's
might get unpulled what are you doing
jaby the the friggin you guys in the
chat are keeping us safe
on this damn
professional handheld mics have buttons
all right jpq stevens thank you let's go
thank you j.q stevens
asian lee i'm assuming is how you say it
thank you
from asian league a moment of silence
zero or zero
congratulations on one million guys
y'all deserve each and every one
there's one thing about this stream and
does not have good playback value
originally not become a podcast nine
pounds it could be thank you reginald
reginald
moment of silence chats are the best
absolutely
all right achara get in here read a chat
ronald gregory we're gonna make you
productive
not me oh sorry yeah all right always
blaming
all right
achara from
mr and mrs flicks thank you so much for
your super chat that's very nice
congrats my boys thank you mr mrs flix
oh that sounds so much like a movie
thank you for inventing flicks for us
and we me we skipped chris leto john
what does he say chris leto named after
my favorite actor jared leto oh my god
yes sir man you guys hit it keep going
we're gonna stop here what would be so
funny is if for some reason people you
know because people unsubscribe every
day
that would be hilarious i actually think
that'd be really funny i was thinking
i'd be like what's that what's the
ironic part of this because right when
we hit it it is gonna churn a little bit
yeah it's gonna go down a little bit
every day people unsubscribe every time
you upload something josie reviews
congrats on the huge milestone your
videos have helped me when i was moving
and down on my luck thank you for always
being awesome let's go get to two
million now you guys are helping me
thank you josie i appreciate that josie
thank you so much
david you gotta see what your reviews
are david gandy david gandy is the one
who got us this camera david king oh
yeah david gandy i was like because greg
was like hey uh i i need a good lens for
this camera and i'm like you have a g
master 24 millimeter that's a really
good lens yeah you know [ __ ] you all
know what he's talking about everyone in
this chat knows what everyone is
tweeting
i i even know it's a cinematography
major g chord 24 what is it that's a g
master the g-max g-master is like
top-of-the-line
that sounds like a sex that's a
provocative ass name for a lens oh you
went below a million you could have uh
voyeuristic people we did not go below a
million
thank you david gandy and congrats on
the house the lenses are now again oh my
god josie you sent your review into your
comment twice no refunds no
hashtag
the girls love john that's the way it
goes that's racist he's something for
the asian one no it's what's wrong with
john
nothing's wrong white white lee
john gets the women i get the guys
that's the way it works here two peas in
a pod yeah two halves of the same apple
or whatever the phrases cores in one app
there you go see that's why he gets the
woman he knows it kartik sharma what's
up
i know cardiac sharma well then thank
you read this one jabez cabral hey guys
congratulations on a million subs do you
think obi wan and leia's adventure in
the latest series inspired her to name
her son after him why
yeah because his name's ben
i don't know it is a connection
but i mean she against her
with ben kenobi
down the road doesn't she no no
no oh yeah and a new hope they don't
actually interact with each other
exactly but she knows luke and luke and
the
she's there when obi-wan dies because
yeah yeah but she has no reaction right
it's just luke going no
that looks weird i'm sorry guys i'll be
respecting i never questioned it i
thought like yeah it's ben kenobi makes
sense like why you would name him ben i
i oh i'm my mind is blown right now i
never realized they never interacted
with each other he died and she's like i
guess we need a new hope now
because there's a movie in star wars
called a new hope it was that one yeah
did you realize that what you did
at 2 million why is a char behind the
frame because this lens is such a good
focus and has such a minimal
amount of aspect ratio with the car is
going to have to be back there blurred
minimal amount
achara one achara i don't know the
terminology i call you up to learn
terminology that i have john spit back
at you trash panda discovered you guys
threw schmo down years ago [ __ ] ever
since congrats on the one million oh i
guess that was worth it guys if you
haven't seen our latest showdown match
that was the most fun we've ever had bit
big big fun big fun big big amount of
fun
get in there
say words darth pug pugs are my favorite
dog um thank you for your super chat
congrats you guys are more than
deserving here's to the next million
much love actually
we're gonna stop after this
this is the end of the channel this is
pulling an unes anus and we're shutting
this [ __ ] down
right when this live stream is done yes
we will upload our stranger things
reactions on the jaby kawaii channel
from here on out you did it before and
then we'll go get through
a t-shirt
oh my god josie reviews third time's a
charm dude no refunds jose we are
definitely going to read this super chat
if it's the last thing we do congrats
john i'll read the first sentence you
read the next congrats on the milestone
thank you for helping me get through
some tough times your videos always put
a smile on my face pass the mic to
achara let's get to two milli way to
keep the energy up achara that's real
natural not forced reading i appreciate
that
it was like an exquisite corpse strategy
hd
moment of silence momento de silencio
scott jenkins jank i miss alyssa fool's
day as do i youtube took it down
those pricks still have are they take it
down uh i need the blue regrets
apparently showing my pubic hair is not
a good idea we need to blur greg's mound
and this in the sketch hitting a girl's
face with my crotch was not good it was
a funny ass sketch gold and i down we
still have a community guidelines strike
because it's just
snack cider
eric not eric been here since y'all were
smally y'all are my inspiration behind
my reaction vids congrats well deserved
oh thanks man
i like to think we inspired a whole
generation and even you know a couple
people who've started up a couple
channels with an american reaction
channel oh yeah and an indian review one
channel yeah what yeah we talking about
i think uh check it out i think we're
we're what you call
uh
trendsetters taste blazers what is it
called one
we're trailblazers yes i got tyrone
magnus when a beer if it wasn't for us
blind wave would appear
we're real mavericks here i gotta
recognize the other day at the uh
watching top gun
and he was like hey real rejects right
[Laughter]
and you said yep wait really no oh
that's fine i wish that was true i'm
pretty sure there are guys at the gym
who look at me and think i'm you
are they indian
uh they look like they might be i don't
want to say they are because that would
be racist
into you or indian indian
uh whatever they could be into it
whatever sounds cooler plausible that
movie
channel justin released
you guys are my inspiration hashtag
justice for johnny depp oh
yeah i have a lot of videos on that if
you feel like guys go watch don't watch
the trial watch jaby's videos on johnny
depp watch chaby's comprehensive legal
breakdown omni media in the chat saying
definitely inspire me [ __ ] nah dude
your own thing don't lie omni everybody
go watch omni's thank you universe
rothschild rockefeller morgan appreciate
you earl cheese marvelous films
all right checking back in ronin
unchained congrats gents here's to
another million salute
thank you thank you ronin unchained i'll
drink some of this black you got you
know niraj krishnan
krishna
uh congratulations guys smiley face and
a thumbs up
one of our long enduring supporters how
is it being here jaby was it everything
you wanted it to be and more
i hope so i'm very happy
i got i got bashed by my brother as soon
as i showed up you're doing it wrong
jeremy that was exactly what i was going
to keep changing the topics man i know
that you're flummoxed because there's no
modesty bar you're gonna be fine ethan
fiskus with the awesome name been
watching y'all for years i love your
videos and you never disappoint here's
to two mil you got you got your [ __ ] cut
up for you i'm not gonna stress myself
to two million all right jon get us
there all right start finding the videos
yes i know what people like
it's marketable it's uh yeah i'm a big
marketable ability guy i'm excited what
i'm really excited for this next path is
is uh the stuff with coy and sally
especially that's been a lot of work
that we've been doing and i think that's
going to be stuff you guys are really
good it's going to be awesome when he
does the 2 million uh live stream
without you and he spends like an hour
on the one dollar super point
that's going man
was like i want to have a live show and
i'm like well you can't spend an hour on
like one question man yeah or else
you're going to be there
you get paid per hour so don't don't
spend forever on campus 10 hours every
stream
zender bro is one of my best friends no
two simultaneously so i'm like yeah you
know i just want to say that y'all
inspire me to keep creating content
y'all cure my depression oh xander bro
we are now covered by medical yeah your
insurance is certified we are often
pharmaceutically improved
thank you this super chat is part of
your deductible you don't need to see
actual therapy or get actual medication
just uh come here nah man it's a wrap we
are a supplement pineapple we are graded
by the fda what do you like about our
channel versus your channel
what's better she doesn't have to do
anything
[Laughter]
i don't have to do anything on youtube
yeah that's right no you guys are really
funny and you offer really great insight
and i i like
how you guys bounce off of each other
and yeah it's fun did i tell you how
good she was at lying she sounds like
she's lying i like how you put on your
best like silk voice dude i tell you how
good she wasn't lying
thank you achara that was really sweet
pineapple
how to receive a compliment started
watching you guys when i started high
school and now i'm 21. do you feel old
yet and still enjoying your content
every day keep it up rejects and
congratulations we do thank you so much
man
we raised yeah your personality formed
from you absorbing us i hope we rubbed
off on you well there's these guys at
the gym nero and joe oh and uh cool
they've been watching me since high
school
yeah i've been watching this since high
school and uh i love i love uh hanging
out talking to them
i'm like but once you turn 18 we're not
talking to each other anymore is what i
told them
what's your of age this is this is
awkward now that you're adults yeah no
they're like 20 or something like that
yeah that's awesome yeah that's great
talking thank you i'm glad you stuck
around strategy hd thank you for the
moment of silence thank you strategy hd
chris
again yes sir man you guys hit it
watching since infinity war hells yeah
oh i thought that was infowars watching
this appearance with alex jones on
infowars the turn of the frogs game
i you are gonna
you know it's a microphone right
you know you're you're shouting into the
microphone right now sometimes i play
this [ __ ] back and i'm like we got so
loud there yeah i feel like sorry you
have a compressor on that yeah yeah i
don't know all right gabby it's time to
get in there and fix everything
youtube will clip it down
carter love joy john
saw you literally put your mouth right
into it and you just yell oh you gotta
learn but i also am facing you gotta
learn the traumas technique
she goes like that yeah like a stand-up
comedy yeah
carter love joy congrats i love you
buddy congrats guys one million love the
content you guys bring and here's to
many more subscribers for the real
rejects hashtag road to 2 million why
are there more reaction people in here
and people in the chat are saying
there's more we got mary cherry hey mary
cherry heard you coming to america cody
leech freaking love you all my mind
entertainment omni media and tyrone why
don't you just text me tyrone and omni
media idm marriage and i'll give you
guys the rest of you guys my phone
number two while we're at it oh strife
don't cry but but do cry all right
thanks strife um
thanks mary cherry
she's coming to america i think i
decided
uh doing collabs and stuff
you're replacing koi's pin messages
don't you ever say i'm too drunk to
drive yeah oh congrats to my favorite
american dream she does great movie
reactions it's a great movie and show
reaction yeah she does great reactions
everybody goes she's really fun
do it in fact one time i like [ __ ]
something up in the title or description
box and she messaged me and i was able
to fix it because of her i had no idea
hey tyrone what [ __ ] you did it
that was you just did what john did yeah
went like this
i went like this that hurt me at least
um but tyrone man thank you tyrone life
he's one of the nicest guys
what tyron's really nice i love when he
uh reacts to you know
woke content
how's it going
that makes everyone happy everyone
agrees when that happens
i'll watch our videos and his i'm like
we got two very different opinions about
this piece of property right now
life of nature that's all right tyrone
is actually very very nice he's a great
guy he's very very very helpful too very
honest
he's an honest guy he's in person on
camera very honest guy
he's great he's yeah i i love tyrone
when donald glover did his music video
uh tyrone was not afraid to say his
honest feelings about that music video i
remember that
austrians got a lot of other things
these days don't get you slipping
actually last time i saw tyrone we had
the most fascinating like in-depth comp
we didn't talk about youtube we just
talked about life stuff for like three
hours and it was so fun because his
opinions differ so much from olivia's
opinions and it was fun while i'm like i
wonder if they're gonna get into a fight
it was really fascinating to watch
happen but no that's what's cool about i
i it doesn't matter if we have different
opinions as long as we can have an
actual conversation then i'm and i'm
fine what's crazy is they're the same
size you wouldn't know it because he
looks like eight feet tall on camera
surprisingly not that tall
hope you're watching tyrone i'm breaking
the secret you are not that tall of a
guy
it's okay he's muscle bound his baritone
makes up for it uh life of nate i'm
drunk but i love you
as fast as 2014 we got people from the
philippines here jaby's much older than
me by 12 years what spice yeah i found
this out 35 years old i'm learning this
right now and he's not self-conscious
about his age that explains so much
thank you so much nate bobby kett's a
quattro to have all my mind
entertainment here thanks man bobby
cat's a quaddle next up more billion
subscribers more being sweet more being
sweet more b is sweet that was just so
funny to say because coy was the host of
the morbius event and i was like
apparently this is gonna be the next big
thing of all time mobius 2 man i want it
i want it so bad and i want it
un-ironically strife strike guys have no
clue how much this channel means
but we have to explain it to us we
haven't explained it to us with a five
dollar super chat
emojis and in a super chat no but uh
strife no seriously thank you man that
means a lot uh or woman or whatever your
pronoun is because i i i actively try to
get pronouns right now and sometimes i
ask people what's your pronoun and they
laugh at me like i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
when i'm like i'm trying to adjust
considering i'm trying to who knows
who's gonna get offended wait wait wait
was someone someone who was actually
like not uh cisgendered was laughing at
you no i'm saying i don't know if
someone is or is it so i'm asking
sometimes i'll ask like what's your
pronoun and then
people usually just like have that like
gawk that
that snicker yeah and then they'll be
like i'm a guy or something like that
sorry geez you're woke agenda
well i'm like i don't know who i'm gonna
try to accommodate you that happened to
me on stage once at an improv show uh
there's a show and someone was trans i
didn't know that and i was kept calling
the person to heed and and then they
corrected me and i was like oh sorry and
then i spent the rest of the show
paranoid that i like
made the whole audience uncomfortable by
[ __ ] that up i didn't know
yeah you handled it with a try and i
keep calling i keep trying to get that
right with ezra miller but damn do i
mess that up jay
i remember when greg was sad when tom
holland recognized tyrone and not you
came come a long way since then yes yeah
now robert downey jr comes up to me
that's right man
robert downey jr impression joe
i want to put a shoot of armor around
the channel
greg you're my favorite reactor
did i tell you when james juan
recognized me after meeting him three
times and he didn't realize he met me
twice before that happens with famouser
people it used to happen with me and
christian harloff
he recognized me like the third time i
met him he recognized me and he's like
oh yeah you do the reaction videos i was
like
yeah we also like chatted for like an
hour like just six months ago dude like
how do you know we're both asian man
come on exactly
michael mack
left you guys a streamlib's donati is
that mac
michael mac mac the knife your mac
friend oh no no no that's uh that is not
mac murdock no no no guys sorry no
mac is a good dude though ronaldo torres
torres thank you michael mac we will
check the thank you also just hey thanks
for donating here to let us know you
donated there who's the spam in the chat
i got to make sure to block it i'm
checking in here who's the spam
also omni media in the chat says it's
morbid time i am almost compelled to pin
that because it's always morbid time
here at the real reject studios
i am all i give if you're just tuning in
your chats the regular chat is just all
here on my phone right now and yes
jeremy wrong java and i are brothers
don't worry jules we're going to get
more john impressions coming your way
that's what i do i just summoned john
impression out of nowhere
torres torres go ahead sorry uh let's go
congratulations on everything guys
new house thank you so much dream come
true how's your house coming along jaby
uh yeah it's awesome
[ __ ] you jabby
what three bathrooms hey cintel's here
hey centel's here
can we can we actually read that now
before he goes to bed
wait just wait we're not please i'll go
i'll get there hold on let me do it on
my phone
i'll get there in a second one sec but i
want to finish those first great things
just keep on coming what's your favorite
video that you guys uploaded oh easy out
of like all the thousands of videos i
got it off the top of my head
your reaction to the 800 000 subscribers
dance that achara did yeah definitely
yep anything jabby or chara related is
my favorite that we've ever done exactly
yes definitely i still think my favorite
trailer reaction i think this one i can
actually point pinpoint i still think my
favorite one in terms of like this is
why trailer reactions exist
is
wha what are you you say upgrade i was
gonna say okay uh blum house is upgraded
like that trailer i that was one of
those we knew nothing about and that
just like blew my [ __ ] mind that
first time the camera flips around
yeah
that to me was an example of this is why
trailer reactions exist this this [ __ ]
right here and that was one of the
really cool like premiere experiences
too because we got to go see that and
like actually and like logan marsh the
star of the movie came up to us it was
like you guys did that trailer reaction
that's crazy and like yeah it was it was
very much like a cool nerd uh
fulfillment moment that's actually where
i met james one so until yeah i remember
that now sintel says did you really just
give me an old man joke jaby pox upon
your home yeah his super chat was
congrats in the middle let me borrow 20
i'm good for it sintel
no
no i will not lend 20 i just got a house
what are you doing we're doing more
brand deals
brand deals for mortgage and to hire
coins
so
yeah and more and more editing work too
absolutely i think a lot of people at
the top you weren't here at the top you
reported people like the top prepper
people at the top too great
i'm here now prepper people you guys
rock
prepper peeps i hope you guys are
watching jayden those aren't pretty
prepping other channels that i don't
know how to do it
is greg still trying to get that cap to
fit properly
you know moonlights will smith
moonlights as an editor in india hey i
mean i still rewatch how this would work
i still re-watch the upgrade trailer
reaction to this day thanks
what are you doing john i can't i'm
opening up the stream labs because
somebody left his super chat to let us
know they left a stream oh thanks
all right i got the chat down here cool
thanks danny boy
our mix at art x-mas when did you guys
first feel like you made it congrats on
1 million subscribers
i think it was when i was able to there
was one month i'll never forget this
there was one month
like the the big part of my life was
when i was working a full-time job at uh
i was a receptionist at a doctor's
office and then i was doing youtube in
between shifts
and
then uh i had no money saved at all
but i really had to get out of that job
i just had to get out of that job and
and then there was one month where i was
like you know
if i quit my job i will have more time
to do youtube and if i'm able to upload
every day i might be able to make my
rent
and then i did make my rent granted it
wasn't like i was making a bunch of
money so i had to borrow money for i had
to do like i had to do postmates in the
beginning to still make ends meet
occasionally borrow like a little bit of
money from mom once in a while in the
beginning you were also living in a
studio apartment with six dudes yeah
that's true and we did not there was too
many intimacy problems in that studio
apartment i'll tell you that much so
yeah that was uh that was the time i
don't really know it's never really it's
always i talk about this with heavy
spoilers quite a bit is it we're
constantly feeling like we're back at
the beginning all the time and that we
have to like
always be like so on top of it and then
like this could all go away any day and
it doesn't feel like we've just made it
rick and close by it always feels like
if we're not focused on growing that the
channel's just gonna die like we don't
know how to just stay steady but it
feels like we always have to focus on
growing that's partially youtube's fault
because they have all these youtube for
all the things you've done for us they
have like they have like all these they
have these messages that pop up and says
you did great this time it was all you
you did it you did a fantastic thank you
keep it up they say [ __ ] in there though
your views have fifty percent more views
than usual people are watching a little
bit longer this time for thumbjindal or
our head editor from prepper uh super
chattered us because he knows damn well
he's going to get this money back
he's like i'm going to just get it back
for that i need some strangers here's
some money to give to me later
greg i didn't realize you had the
emotional damage andre
what does that mean oh emotional you
don't know what emotional damage is no
emotional damage you don't know that guy
oh you haven't seen stephen hee
oh those would be some fun reactions
that you guys would really love to do
maybe one day oh you know that's
something that will get you guys views
you should watch steven heath thanks
megan one day we'll get our plaque
uh marvelous film says you guys are all
natural entertainers i can listen
anytime what's funny is this is the
first stream we've done in a very very
very very long time that's about us
so it feels weird to read things about
us when normally it's like there's
questions
uh tyler james we're just getting
through the super chats i'm not sure
what are you what are you loading john
i'm trying i don't like this [ __ ]
somebody left there were there was
somebody like you're trying to access
the stream i could get to stream like
somebody left a super chat to let us
know that they uh i thought you had
streamlabs open
i did but it's uh they've changed their
ui don't worry we're gonna we are
investing
this part we're just gonna sir you guys
have probably noticed we've been doing a
little more brand new like we are
investing and getting like better stream
equipment not just older coins
we're doing quite a bit can you afford a
dinner table for john like a fold-out
dinner table we're going to have a
different we're getting a new desk and
everything we're going to be setting up
a new uh for the new space we're
literally like what are the problems we
have and how do we avoid these problems
from here on now maybe maybe a mouse pad
for his leg now we're going to we get a
new mouse pad you see how dinged up that
is look at this mouse pad we've been
working with for
for [ __ ] ages like like that's just a
mouse that's not a mouse pad but i mean
mouse you know what i mean
three to four hours of sleep at night
for the past couple weeks
is also where did you get that mouse uh
i don't know we just haven't replaced it
uh he doesn't know where he got that
mouse he has no idea i mean we've had it
for so long my dude yeah so long
so long what is this bait you're doing
did you get it to us i've given you more
collabs or jaby all right
i won't talk about the mic
they are making another paranormal
activity the other side that is great
news thank you
john what's going on
john's doing i have no idea it's not
that insane i'm just trying to get the
stream labs up and it's not can we
access it from a different computer so
we could at least read it i will try
because we got some super chats to get
through i will try to their their ui is
different right now so
oh anyhow i will go back to this don't
make fun of john you guys are very
defensive
well i mean i'm not doing something
ridiculous that's all you smell funny he
just got the he's got super defensive
john your
your defensive attitude is making making
the livestream tension
i am pleased
i am not defense i
am in
control it's all part of the plan g
congratulations john you got a million
subscribers there's anything that john
can do is he could just randomly
surprise me with the funniest
drop sending over you guys you guys
should go to disneyland now
thanks nicole elliott
uh get back in here have you guys done
the star wars chase carter says john
what are you doing fix everything
that is what it's what her attitude is
just fix it all john i cannot answer
that i'll try and fix everything one day
i'll be able to fix it hold on have you
guys done all these hours right now boys
at a girl's place right now have you
done the star wars i don't care no i
haven't oh my god you have to do you got
to do this
yes we got amazing we got invited to
star wars celebration and you didn't go
john and i got invited and because you
got a million subscribers yeah i'm like
sorry we're going to get a million
subscribers don't want to go
we should have done a live stream no i
mean i was honest i was like i have to i
have to start moving that weekend and i
was also like we also got stranger
things in ob1 coming up we can't just be
away
so yeah shout outs top priority shouts
out to homegirl rachel jackson aka now
rachel o'hara who just gave me a ring
i'm gonna have to hit her up but she has
been on the channel as well mister
downtown oh she was trying to be we're
trying to work with elgato right now
actually believe it or not a minute
since we've spoken fix stuff tomorrow i
feel bad is greg and that guy in the
middle brothers no that guy no no no his
name is guy album different last names
galba galba guy we just happened to look
alike and uh are there some really sweet
comments here oh i just lost it there
was a really sweet one uh alta famar
says vamar you followed your passion now
look how far you've come my passion was
always to be on youtube yeah ever since
i was a kid that was my passion is that
i want to be on everyone's computer and
phones
keep having fun and being yourselves
thanks i'll tell you oh you caught up
you found it good wow john's so good at
this you're back in action so john knows
what he's doing
chris ruth this is where john comes in
that's a special thing went away john
[ __ ] it up what the [ __ ] john i'm just
complimenting damn it i was just about
to you know i was about to read it no
guys ah failure it tastes terrible
though
thanks lisa
i was thinking the same thing emotional
wait wait
guys
who's the guy who's spamming so i can
stop them naked hd person hold on you uh
don't kill him i just put user um
hopefully i'm putting the right person
can y'all
you someone's super chat at greg and
tell him to react to steven he with john
i'm uh i am filipino in italian i'm
tired okay something about changing
only dummy's got 1 million subscribers
congrats love you guys hell yeah all
righty chris roth we're back in action
favorite review i think yours got
shuffled out of order because we talked
to you about this but uh i think the 21
and over review was also very fun to
shoot because we just kept saying jeff
chang a lot
i think uh yeah that's a fun one
mandy i just was really pleased that
that review got so big because i loved
that movie and it was one of those weird
like this is just a random cult movie
that we reviewed and it popped off which
one mandy oh yeah it was a fun one
i love that where are we at here on the
back here play your player oh my god
oh my oh my you hit 1 million
subscribers yahoo congrats oh my
why is that you who congrats is that
what you thank you
thank you back your play because of the
you that's where my mind went i'm gonna
i prefer jaby's reactions but he's too
cocky what a weird thing to say i prefer
jaby but he's too cocky
that's what we all that's a comment i'm
thinking off camera no
you're not
yeah you're not cocky you're just
egotistical and think you know
everything there's just the difference
between cocky
there's cocky and there's there's i'm
definitely nitpicky
i'm definitely
times two in here and not enough in here
definitely never analytical that i don't
agree with what
i'm writing here and not in here what
are you talking about sometimes you come
too much from here and not the emotional
experience did you see my top gun
reaction
did you man that is my one thing i will
point to for all things moving forward
i had an emotion
did you see me crying exactly that's
that's my claim to fame
uh clam the fam all right uh tarka 71 go
ahead greg sorry
uh yeah sorry this is the stream we make
fun of jon for messing up i make fun of
jaby for anything i could think of in
the moment for existing
for being here for showing up it's a
rose central that's what happens when
you're
roasting been here since the 2014
godzilla trailer so proud of you guys
john their super chats are not showing
on screen
wow oh no it's just me how come you
can't manage everything and host at the
same time modest detection is everything
everywhere all at once how come you
can't be corey coleman
oh i would love to be corey coleman did
you know corey coleman he has that [ __ ]
down when he's streaming what do you
mean you feel him corey coleman is is a
king
hey
you do two of my jobs and i just do one
so you're you're all i have to do is
talk
and then tell tell jaby
when we can't see the screen but 15. no
one can hear you a chart i don't know
i'm hoping my voice
we have some lip readers in the chat
so you read the uh dark one life
life of nate been here since 2014 love
y'all also
i'm buzzed at the moment but i wanted to
say i watched top gun twice within 12
hours it deserves rewards so he's
drinking for you
and congratulations
dude top gun too i can't wait to watch
it again how was it on universal imax it
was great it was beautiful they take up
the full screen yeah uh yes sometimes
sometimes yeah it was okay cool
i think so yeah
not just the dialogue scenes no during
the dialogue since it didn't then what's
the point in watching i know right i
know why would i what it was it's going
to be i want to see
garbage start over i want to see tom
cruise
that was the punch line but that wasn't
the whole joke oh what was the rest of
it kablabus you're just gonna have to
watch back the stream all right because
michael mack sent in a stream lab
congrats guys been
subbed to the channel since the lead up
to endgame
so like three and a half years happy
thanksgiving all your success shout out
to koi too big love from
scotland don't let greg do an accent
don't let greg do an accident
so you got to read that
this is the ugly truth
[Laughter]
what is this voice gerard butler
popcorn says congrats greg's and john
where are you gonna put the new play
button at jaby's house under my bed
right yeah
i want him to step on it every morning
that's right with mine like arthur from
uh moon knight
john
are you texting people in the middle of
the stream rape now you're talking
rachel's hitting me up hey rachel thanks
i'll talk to rachel which rachel jackson
rachel jackson rachel o'hara rachel is
married now oh [ __ ] and good for you oh
i don't need to talk to her
where are
you i don't know if we have that
capability here yet oh we're stuck on
the same suit
don't worry we got this
uh if our computer wouldn't work
bella congrats john and greg very
deserved jaby i love the video you
uploaded of you and greg as kids have a
good day y'all oh
anything to capitalize off the greg
albert brand i tried to get greg to
react to it
i tried to get greg to react to he's
like i just watched it thanks
i watched it so fast
i watched too late i watched it in speed
mode
i watched the two times speed mode
special shouts out to friend of the
channel rachel uh she's been on a few
videos here we all went to improv back
in the day it's been a long time she's
been in japan which is a wednesday by
the way which was a wednesday by the way
it's good it's good to have you it's
good to chat greg let john what does
that mean what does that mean once it
says gregor john exclamation mark gregor
john just let me greg let john do
whatever he wants whatever it is let me
do it
john's so unprofessional i am the least
professional where's the boxers i sent
two super chats that weren't there tyler
james we might just be uh behind you in
the cute in the queue
morbius sponsor yes dr stinky we
absolutely want a morbius sponsor
morbius uh sweep
2019. don't worry guys i got i got your
chats under control here all righty here
we go here we go one
extra six wow thank you guys extra rice
one extra rice chucus roman and moving
it i don't know why it does that oh no
it's lost forever yeah we'll never get
through this
all right okay well you guys do i have
this chat here so when you got to reload
that just i mean that are so good right
there you got it you got it you got it
again okay
read it now read it congratulations guys
i've been here from the days when the
other brother used a screen name and the
other brother used his real name oh my
god that's right you were anthony yeah
at one point i was yes oh but that
identity is dead now
you're dead naming me don't do that
that's not nice what does the name
anthony mean
uh i forgot
no favorite of god something about being
smart i forgot what it was though
uh something about remembering things
one extra rice one extra rice chucus
roman congratulations mr greg and daddy
john step on me please
daddy john man daddy john all right it's
dungeon time
it's rejects after dark daddy john is
the sex beast man that's right man we're
kinky here at the real rejects thanks
man anthony means priceless one
or highly praiseworthy dude
from the roman family name antonius oh
nice i wish that
i needed a more accurate one my name
means vigilant and watchful no it
doesn't yeah it does uh tell jaby did
you really oh that's old yeah yeah
guys i got i got this under control what
does greg mean john i'm trying to take a
pressure off so to be awake
to be watchful that's why you're so woke
kartik sharma
did you catch that joke greg yep it was
great i heard i hear every conversation
in this room right now
because that's why you're woke because
you're awake
i think i qualify as it's pretty cool
guys
i suppose yes
i suppose i'm awoke bros
what's going on
what are you doing
what's going on john what's going on
what's happening over here john i'm
sorry
yeah and all the conversation we got a
live stream going i'm sorry i'm sorry
rachel wants to call us like seriously
you guys strike all three of us are just
looking at you
all right drive like seriously you guys
have gotten me through so much
thanks
thanks buddy right it's a super super
chess like
cap out at a certain account right geom
films thanks man oh
oh that was one of my favorite videos
from youtube ever when he made fun of
you guys running out of content yeah for
the spiderman no way home i laughed so
hard at that video i think i left harder
than you guys did
i thought that was so funny that was one
of the funniest things when you guys
were reacting to weather yeah and then
the lottery ball i thought it was genius
yeah that was one of the funniest things
anyone's ever done about us yeah new
rockstars are in the chat and so is pop
culture podcast it's never eric which
which new rockstar is this do better
eric is it is it philip is it new
rockets is actually in the chat what the
[ __ ] oh yeah they show up sometimes hold
on i know rockstars people it's never
eric oh that sucks what are you talking
about that's sad the rest of the team is
great eric is sometimes here no they're
all right and i love phil molina i'm
kidding i'm kidding
philip and eric i don't know the other
new rock stars but i love filipino and
zach we know zach zach zack zack is
great zack the producer yeah zach's
awesome
i don't know zach
john is pretty handsome yeah i hear it
all the time chris ayers uh he says he
looks like we passed the super chat
johnny
john we need you to focus a little bit i
am we need you to focus i have been get
serious i have i need you to get serious
now this is a serious stream from here
on you're going backwards i know because
if we miss somebody
but i don't think we did
his name is chris yes i've seen chris
chris what ares or something like that
just control effort
and then we'll go to a stream from
forever
it's going to destroy everything i'll
find it man
we don't need koi if we have koi here
it's going to just be even more chaotic
uh on kit is asking if a char is okay
now yes i'm good are you are you so good
achara you're the best dude new
rockstars is the king will never ever
mindset says yes one million been
watching you guys for quite a while and
it's been so cool seeing this channel
grow to what it is today stay true to
yourselves and i wish you guys well in
the future heart heart heart heart heart
i think i don't think we missed this
chris guy alls i'm saying is typically
stream people people say we missed it
but
nine times out of ten we it's just up
next all right just to keep things in
order here uh or in a little bit of
structure i'm gonna keep your name in
mind right now and then we're gonna go
through these and then we're gonna go
back and see if we can find it so tom
jindal is asking where did my super chat
go
we'll get we're going to get to you a
lot of people's people think we just
skipped them and that's why john can't
be texting people right now this is all
your fault john write a text for you
this is all yours no it's fine challenge
the way these streams go is always like
it's always like okay we got to keep
things moving and then you will drift
and start to banter with somebody and
things will stop moving
and then we kind of share the weird role
of like we gotta batter through the
noise yeah we got this kenneth rather in
junior marathon stranger things four
last night crazy episode seven right i
didn't see it yet i'm on episode well
it's crazy jaby i'm i'm sorry do you
want to know what happens no don't tell
me is everyone in this stream cody lee
congrats guys hell of an accomplishment
thank you cody leech cody leech has a
great youtube channel oh he does i want
to make sure that is the exact channel i
want to think about
are you the one who did the dexter
breakdowns i'm pretty sure that was you
carter love joy one second that's one
minute cody leach man love the content
hold on yeah yeah i watched when i was
watching dexter new blood there wasn't a
lot of content for the extra new blood
and you were i watched your videos every
week and you perfectly echoed my
thoughts on the finale too someone
apologized for sending two super chats
um
never cody leach all right thank you
cody leech carter lovejoy congrats on 1
million love this content and here's to
many more subs oh no let's go hashtag
wrote to 2 million thank you carter
lovejoy means a lot this is the guy
actually hey chris o'leary that's what i
was trying to say thank you chris found
you first video was the russian sleep
experiment oh with ariana bostery who's
now married by the way did you know this
one's married yeah everyone's getting
married ariana whatever
the [ __ ] ball of energy that oreos
unrefined energy yeah man it's like yeah
unenriched uranium g-o-m george what's
going on george the channel's been
blowing up too everyone who wants to
blow up on youtube cover johnny depp
amber hurt it does the best oh god isn't
that right you guys
i don't know what you're talking about
why are you looking at it i thought i
banned this naked person hold on it's
this is we're in the past we're in the
past all right in the past okay well let
me know when we're back in the present
we got this very much in the gom films
one million congrats thanks gom man
i feel like half the reason you got
there was because of him
half the reason half the reason you mean
like three fourths of the reason yeah
chris bustin
greg first hooked me to the real rejects
with two words we've got this one
already didn't we maybe it's a
resubmission thanks chris
i might have read it earlier
tj3 so happy for you guys but let's take
a second and thank the real mvp dr
michael morbius
absolutely at your service did you guys
see more reasons no no yeah why not i'm
waiting for it to streaming is it
streaming john and i and koi were the
only well koi like liked it a lot coy
liked it and hey koi like g i was i
asked koi like is this like something
you're doing because sony hired you
he's like no i really liked him
more bass and i love all the impressions
i'm able to do what are some of y'all's
favorites of impressions
uh i love a good john
nick offerman impression
john do your nick off you guys know nick
offerman ron from parks and recreation
yes i know that yeah
i was saying yes in my mind all right
let everyone give john the spot everyone
everyone shut up
sometimes at night when i'm particularly
cold i think of jaby kawai's strong bear
arms
clapping me like a youth
i like you know i watched an improv show
with greg white not my best offer i
think that you and greg were in the same
improv show actually at the off of
lancashire and greg did it
yes yes
uh greg did an al pacino impression
about the weather
and it was amazing this is like the best
weather man ever
yeah
yeah you're doing a weather impression
and someone asked you a question from
the audience and you tried to answer it
but you had no idea what the [ __ ] i
think i i think i think i know what i
said i think i think it's coming back to
me a little bit of what i imagined al
pacino or i think i was like
tonight it's going to be
raining outside
[Laughter]
that you also do you guys did uh johnny
depp back in the day
uh
all the time
all right let's keep it going johnny
here please john stay on track what are
you doing guys
yeah giroudi so happy for you guys been
a silent watcher since your reaction for
the flash tv show
oh
you okay there i totally stopped
watching that [ __ ]
on this
and no one was watching and i was like
what the [ __ ] the point of covering
this anymore
the show stopped being interesting you
mean you just do this for money greg
no
i do it for
recognition you mean you don't do this
just for the your joy of watching it no
peregrine actually believe it or not
that's actually a big factor in what
john and i do is like will we enjoy this
should we watch this
that's why we've not covered many things
is because we're like this simply won't
do you ever get accused of faking your
reactions oh sure dude it's been [ __ ]
it's like almost 10 years of this
day there are endless bits of evidence
that people lay out as to why we're fake
always our our our model for everything
we do is always in the middle ground of
like will people watch this and are we
interested in it too again if we're not
we just simply don't yeah and we get a
lot of crap for not covering things that
we're not interested in well it's the
three bubbles right because like what
you want to watch what the audience
wants is the algorithm once yeah
parentage yeah i remember the day you
guys wanted to make a patreon and i knew
you'd have success
the channel has been my favorite youtube
channel for like seven years keep it up
you get preparing to redeem your form
your other nick offerman yeah the improv
wasn't good so i was like i got a
pairing i've got h john benjamin stuck
in my head that's why lance door because
i've heard bob's burgers more recently
than anything they've offered all-time
favorite series to react to
oh golly i wish i could have reacted to
daredevil yeah the first season
uh
oh
oh i mean
the one that we reacted to one that we
reacted to i mean nothing topped the one
division experience for me
again it's like that was that was such a
unique experience for us and then i knew
that like this is something we have to
like kind of
do
because this is kind of built around i i
i mean when that
show
ended that night i remember before we
started recording i remember being
really sad because i was like i've never
had an experience with a show like this
where everyone just won't stop talking
about it like off camera i was talking
about it everyone were all theorizing
and uh i was actually like sad to let
one division go so yeah i think one
division was a very and i think it was a
special that also was a special point
for our channel too i think that's when
we started to like regain momentum
there's actually mandalorian season two
but then one division was when we really
started to regain momentum
and uh yeah fortunately we're genuinely
interested in marvel so that just pans
out really well for us that we really
like the marvel stuff i had the same
experience with the boys
boys is great we love the boys
that's one of my favorite shows boys is
terrific i i actually really really
enjoyed i don't know
i don't know if it would be like my
all-time favorite but it uniquely sticks
out i really enjoyed the experience of
doing the chucky series yeah that was my
second one i was gonna say because it's
a horror series but it was also like so
gratifying just how actually really good
it was the more the more you can we
watch stuff when we're we come like a
unaware that there's a camera that's
when it's the most fun yeah it's like
we're just having a really fun time
watching this and we would be we would
be like this regardless of this yeah
because sometimes you like lock yourself
into a show where you're like would i
really be watching this if it wasn't
because
you don't know if you're gonna like a
show or not sometimes um but then we but
most of the time we're very fortunate
where we end up really liking the show
captain america atl love you guys thank
you captain america atl slice of games
100 oh yeah
connie saying what's up connie connie
got us these mics oh very cool johnny
you met connie actually at the cinemark
screenings conference oh that's right
wow dear we are always morbid just uh
a lot of people found us through these
one division reactions apparently oh
nice uh jaby is adopted yes
uh you didn't actually read connie's uh
super chat oh yeah my bad
congratulations buddy thank you connie
good just texting me so incredibly happy
and proud of you guys celebrations soon
yes absolutely yes you are on you are on
the vip list for celebrations connie oh
yeah
rejects celebration we don't want greg
to do whatever he wants
john pause the chat yes i was trying to
go to zoo funk congratulations from a
navy vet didn't you comment on our top
gun video i i think i started to replace
yeah yes yes i hope you enjoyed the
movie and thank you for being here uh
let's keep it going i hope you and your
uh navy buds enjoy xander brown don't
worry jaby i'll read you could read the
quote and you could do his voice y'all
you could do you all inspired me to keep
creating content the real rejects
notifications cure my depression and
make me realize all right i should react
too i'm lazy
why is everyone this voice is very
this is not how most people say
hello keep it up
thanks xander bro keep it going man i'm
just keeping it going dude
tyler
no i mean if you have real depression
don't be afraid to seek real help for it
too you know there's always so much
watching people can do to make you feel
better you should make the best of real
rejects compilation tyler james good i
take hours we should just hire someone
to do it thousands of videos come
through
watch everyone in 10 years we'll have it
ready mr downtown take it away john
congratula congratulations guys love to
see you relax to your first vid we have
done a reaction to that first vid we did
that's up here on the
channel good good
hey
happy one million my name is greg tube
seems sexist only have the lady in the
back hey i've been the only one trying
to actively include her yeah charlie
i'll move on
i'll move but a charge doesn't even
really want seats
john wants her to take over that's not
happening switch seats every 10 minutes
i said you come by and then you show up
with a chara and now i can't have other
people come by and the charge like
freaking racist
ice cream where's the ice cream freezer
do you want me to get it for you yeah
chara what the [ __ ] asmr you're supposed
to be my best friend to char asm ice
happy 1 million my name is greg 2
oh dude thanks greg yeah
there's a thing when greg's meet other
greg because john is such a common name
and he's like hey john that's me that's
one of my opening lines to people is my
name is john it's most people's name
yeah but when greg meets another greg
actually when i was at the the wedding a
few months ago
the person i was had to walk down the
aisle with it was a guy named greg and
he had curly hair too and
i was like
you
stay the [ __ ] away from me oh you
weren't like you were like hashtag
variants nope i don't want anything to
do with it i think you would try to over
shadow me at all times it would have
been like hancock you couldn't get two
things
just so you guys know your videos make
my day oh i'm glad aaron writer this
comment this is why is in the back
she's doing the thing the coolest shirt
and pants comes when they come here
isn't that right achara sit in the back
cara says yes that's how you and smile
things smile
i try to smile more are you doing back
here
when you smile a little bit
come on come on
lind productions you guys inspired me to
go into filmmaking since early 2014
which led me in uh to go into making
filmmaking at uw milwaukee what we're
doing is filmmaking as i'm now in my
second year as a film major thank you
guys so much for all
the years dude a lot of my scratching
thank you you said you wanted chocolate
i didn't know and you just
it's on the mic
lind productions non-dairy oh my god i
feel like i've seen your instagram lin
production thank you lin productions
um dude good best of luck to you man
doria sundar took the opportunity to
screw up i think it's really easy making
it in the film business so you chose the
right avenue man anyone can do it get a
death scream all over your ship there's
like also thousands of people come out
here here and they [ __ ] always
accelerate their careers first you're
trying so after coming on the real
rejects also shouts out to black john
mclean in the chat anyway
hello guys congratulations on the
million also hey there jaby looking
great i know it's all thanks to john
oh thanks
this chastity oh what a beautiful oh
that's a beautiful name beautiful yeah
body dysmorphia too
i have uh i have a body morph yes i have
bodies i have a morph suit
i mean that's sarcastically i do so i
self-conscious when we film i'm always
like look how
that's your million subscriber scoop
right there
uh pinot noir
self-conscious when we're filming i'm
like that looks so fast
every time i'm on camera i'm like i look
so fat yeah
i'm sorry for feeding you as
this is fine everything's okay and my
method of getting over things is just
talk about it
talk about it once in a while that i
really have john and i both have it
sorry to help you john
you have body dysmorphia oh sure oh sure
oh yeah especially right now because
it's like it's hard to get like good
consistent exercise and keep myself on
like a solid eating regimen so i'm not
as like
fiat as i've ever been the past two to
three weeks we've been because we've
been getting like barely any sleep
without everything we've been doing so i
can move thanks john is uh so we've been
really healthy this is the most
unhealthy thing i've had in a while so
i'm
really happy because i was like we
[ __ ] earned just before coming here i
had lots of bread
rub your faces in it garlic bread toast
french toast a baguette an english
muffin john guerrero is on track
man nick mick i want rejects after dark
to be a real thing i do sauce man sauce
man been a rejection 2015 so proud of
y'all oh i'm proud of you thank you
getting up the courage to send us thank
you man uh yes it is old but i just
pinned it so it's new is that the past
men are we in the past it's all the past
stranger things four by three reaction
is going up tomorrow northman uh we'll
probably do a movie reaction for it when
it comes out the north gate i'm the only
one in this room who has not seen
everything everywhere all at once so i
will be doing a reaction for it on the
channel when it is officially streaming
somewhere please let me do that i tried
finding out people said it was on
digital already and i tried finding it
on amazon and it wasn't i couldn't even
buy it please let me do that reaction
with you i would love to please i'm
doing it
won't be this
i just want to be by myself
yeah that's a good idea i'm just gonna
look at the movie i'm not gonna say good
idea they they might have pushed it or
something because it's doing so well
that like they only just opened it in
the uk and things like that i know
someone who's working with that michelle
yo
i you do shaun t somebody who's not
andy andy lee greg
and jaby are my heroes
[Music]
thanks man that means a lot sean tedious
achara are you saying words when no one
spoke to you
i mean sean tds
sean tds technically spoke to a
character
she's included you're my hero achara now
i try to include you more than jaby does
yeah wait what slice of games remember
me
i talked with you two on google plus a
while ago with other people i was
following
congratulations oh
dude slice of game wait are you saying
you just hadn't donated or you just
donated
uh what's the difference says i just
donated he's he's giving you a hundred
bucks on patreon is that
wait a minute hold on a second so now he
gets to tell you not to watch that's not
jim j
jim what's his name jimbo jimbo yeah
jim uh james stegen james saying
it looks kind of like stegan's in the in
the profile pic but bobby bobby really
loved it google the google plus hangouts
were were like crazy long ago and we
only did a few so like that's yeah
thanks for sticking around
we did a little plenty enough to go with
there's no way we can sustain this is
unsustainable yeah
yes oh my goodness uh bobby quetzalcoatl
uh that's a last name w john for saying
my last name right any old time any old
time thanks bobby yeah heck yeah kartik
sharma happy one mil curious about your
seats because anda is hindi for eggs egg
seeds eggs
egg seeds
and the seed oh cool egg seeds
thank you oh appreciate it we'll send
our uh
the best not
yep they're the best they were given to
us
they're the funnest greatest seats ever
made sean don't worry i'll be managing
this chat
to help you out i'm looking for
something specific
i'm not sure
sean tedious
i don't know my friend's username that's
why i'm looking for a comment but i
don't know their username uh it's sean
tds when i become a big actor i'll
credit you for awesome instead of your
credit in the film so whatever your role
is it'll say it was played by the forum
it'll also super chat much bigger too
don't thank your acting coach or the
director
just thank the reaction dad
says achara if you want to say something
you communicate it to us
sorry thank you achara jesus
christ
british
it's smaller than i had it last time big
fan boys and congrats batman 2 heart of
ice what the winter soldier
hold on
winter soldier in the chat says
did anyone pledge a donation and plan to
pay it later
oh wow
wow can i get one of those after pays
for my super chats where it's like we'll
just charge you twenty four dollars now
you don't get that reference it'll be
like a house
wait it'll be like a house you know
that's right you know you guys don't
want it obviously it's like buying a
house
you don't get that it's part of the same
joke
i don't know this is what happens when
you get a bunch of cinephiles together
you get the references start flying from
amber herd's trial yes she's like when
you buy a house you don't pay it all at
once that was just like that was your
argument i pledged i pledged a donation
and planned it pay later yeah that was
the whole thing i pledged interest
it was funny yeah that sounds really
funny you guys planet mars
greetings from canada
congratulations on reaching
one million in all numerals subs guys
here is hoping cameron monahan
plays cletus cassidy aka carnage variant
in the mcu
he could be a good cleat as cassidy i
would love to see that cameron monahan
also knows how to play a protagonist
really well star wars jedi fallen order
i saw the trailer online i haven't
reacted to it i did not react to the
trailer
pandemic sometimes i watch a trailer
without reacting to it guys what
pandemic jones so happy for you guys
i've been here since my junior or senior
year
six seven years most anticipated
upcoming movies much love you guys dude
i love you pete
shout them out once a month
um
most anticipated movie mission
impossible
uh yeah mission possible looks pretty
great
i don't think so thor loving it's
technically just upcoming so that's fair
thor love and thunder
yes
black panther too anything marvel black
panther two
i'm i i mean i'm the only one who hasn't
seen everything everywhere all at once
so i want to see that my most
anticipated movie is just seeing that
movie again
i've thought about it every day since
i've seen it
um what else is there what else is
coming up there's got to be something
i'm excited for isn't there something
coming out at christmas or whatever
that's pretty big
avatar but that's not avatar
i mean i guess i'm excited for average
that's not my answer
i'm very excited for avatar flash
that's next i mean yes i'm excited black
adam that's the one um sure maybe
usually the movies that are not like big
franchise properties that we really want
to watch those trailers come out like
closer to their actual release date
oh pratham jindal great entertainment on
a sunday morning
oh thanks for thump why aren't you
editing yeah get back to work get back
to editing
work you have one employee right now
who's doing exams you got to make up for
those missing times right you better get
back to editing processing this is your
example i'm not alone
chase gardner says favorite skit was
joker skit love your videos boom
that's what i'm most looking forward to
nope it was fun it was a terrible sketch
it was really funny i found it
and the other ones aren't no not at all
that one is the only funny one and also
the nicholas cage dracula movie i'm also
looking forward to that
yeah
yeah can get nick cage is oh good either
never mind i'm not gonna talk about that
movie scroll a little spider verse two
as well i'm gonna be sick
thank you pratham chase gardner thank
you so much fb
oh my god that is an abject terror
sticker thank you for the the
overwhelming ah jacob nelly
neely
finally nelly you guys deserve it you
guys are way better than get jaby that's
what we try telling people and no one
listens to us but ironically we're not
better than jaby coe no jaby kawai is
much better but
that's when jaby's in his comfort zone
that's right my my not like that is
quite conflicted right now
you don't need to be we've had people
say they prefer you but they also backed
it with your [ __ ] that was one person
this is also wonderful i prefer jaby
despite cockiness
mcrae 2000 congratulations on one
million boys here's a hard question for
you you have to sit down and watch a
whole cinematic universe back to back
including tv series what universe would
you choose and why which one's the
shortest breaking bad universe
dude yeah
better call saul
i mean uh that's the last one uh
breaking bad
el camino i know that's right then
better call saul do you watch better
call saul i'm caught up i haven't
watched any of the new season yet oh my
god the last episode
when i eat late at night after a long
day i'll turn on better call saul and i
just caught up can i just borrow your
your thing to watch it
my amazon account
it's on amazon i mean i buy it off
amazon yeah can i just uh do you still
have the thing there are other websites
where you could stream it illegally but
i don't do that because i want the hd
quality okay so
i'd love to borrow your rental yeah i
love
love better call saul man that is a
great answer to that i feel like of all
the comprehensive universes that only
stays good if i'm being totally honest
with you you guys know i used to smoke
weed all the time you did yeah believe
it or not guys uh sometimes i've done it
you smoked a wee people still i'm like
not high at all right now people always
think i'm high
um but every once in a while i go you
know it'd be great to just like get
really high and watch all of the
breaking bad universes
sometimes i just wanted to see that's
like that would be dude that'd be the
dream right there very very carve out a
whole month
and just watch all of that i remember
when you finally watched it you were so
late to it oh my god i was obsessed when
i finally got into it that pilot
that breaking bad still breaking bad
best pilot i've ever seen did you ever
see the breaking bad uh malcolm in the
middle crossover yeah that was funny
the snl one was that snl no he's just
his own thing that he decided to do for
some reason i thought it was us no that
was like an online sketch thing yeah or
a charity thing i don't know melon maze
melanie
wait wait wait wait wait wait mcrae
everyone answer this question what
universe i only answered it john you go
first
and then achara you better make a quick
char universe all of the comprehensive
elements oh
golly that's not breaking bad
ugh dragon ball z
definitely dragon ball
or the cop cinematic universe
oh really no i wouldn't never even see
god i'm like what has movies and shows
what it's an indian reference dragon
ball
no it's not should we watch that rr
movie yeah that's all i hear about just
watched it i just watched it time to
step on jabby you're so annoying you
know that i keep trying to get you to
watch indian stuff for me and you're
like oh we were going to do that for
ourselves it's different and it's the
biggest movie in the world it just never
happens i'm like greg can you please
watch this for me and i'll put it on my
channel no yeah we're going to do it for
us nope no you guys watch it watch it
thank you achara give a char the mic get
out yeah
chara knows what jar knows what's up she
gets it shark gets it
uh that's how we're gonna get our next
million we're gonna we're gonna get your
whole audience from jaby koi all right
how
would that upset you if we got to three
million subscribers and that two million
was from jaby koey
would that be like what the [ __ ] greg
why did you do that
huh i would be very happy for you
in the court of law he said those words
i'm going with the dark universe it's
very easy franchise to watch all of wait
wait do you want to the one
the time crisis
yeah and uh if you want to throw in
dracula untold the unofficial you gotta
you gotta watch all the ones from like
the early
universal monsters oh wait well there's
a big one
my young gulati says i'm going through
chemotherapy you guys are getting me
through it thank you oh oh man that
means a lot thank you absolutely i'm
glad we're i'm glad we're able to bring
some joy along david gandy found us when
he was recovering from cancer and but so
they we that's our your demographic yeah
people who are recovering from cancer
that's right we help that's that's our
main audience morale on the way back to
you
you me and i hope you know if you've
been watching us that that is our sense
of humor yeah so
i hope we didn't always on the virgin
outlet did i actually offend i've become
a little more sensitive the crimson
ghost we are in contact with sally she's
coming back chris leto greg and john rap
battle at two million subs melanie will
melanie leblanc melanie we love you
thanks for all the laughs did you guys
pick franchises before we move on to
melanie that you would watch all of
breaking bad is the best answer because
it's got multimedia and all of its good
it's hard to get to the universe
the witcher cinematic universe i can
watch that all day oh he's got games
yeah they got games and stuff are you
still in contact with sally yeah i've
said this several times
she's coming back he's coming back
coming back
all right melanie leblanc thanks for all
the laughs throughout the years first
youtube then patreon congrats guys
what's your least favorite show you've
reacted to
oh god uh on patreon we watched jessica
jones season two and we just stopped oh
that was a bummer couldn't get through i
remember we just stopped yeah it was
like [ __ ] this this is boring [ __ ] not
that enjoyable nothing's worse than
boring
okay i don't want to answer this
question
where was it
um
no you hate the witcher
or you don't like the witchers you don't
like the witcher
season two is fine i guess
season one's definitely better season
one is yeah yeah yeah season one yeah
season one's better yeah i like the
witcher yeah it's better everyone's like
just just let achara watch it
i'm not alive after the first episode of
the witcher from season one i was like
uh
why the [ __ ] did we agree to do this
yeah this is daunting
and then by the fourth episode i was
like this is [ __ ] great damn
oh what we do in the shadows i'll watch
that whole uh uh franchise
that's a good one
the show is great the movie's great all
the above dude melanie melanie my dear
how's it going probably jessica jones
season two you guys don't have to stare
the whole time if you don't want to oh
good i get the vibe when people want to
leave it's okay omni media john i will
hold it down for until midnight
and then i gotta prep stranger kisses
yes yes
hey omni media congrats boys you deserve
it i want to say thank you guys again
for all being here by the way yes okay
it's a good time to leave it sure
you
thank you omnimedia michael b go follow
him where'd we get this shirt by the way
someone in the chat asked i got these
off at box lunch box lunch
we didn't wear any stranger things
shirts for any of the stranger things
videos and i was like it's the final
episode we got i'm going to go to box
lunch today and pick us up some shirts
john
thank you for doing that too
wait how many episodes of stranger
things have you guys watched
oh man there's so much good stranger
things
yeah i know we're here we're here doing
this instead
[Laughter]
get the fudge out and go watch stranger
things oh my god hey dude the last
episode shut up greg it's so long
another view
another view congratulations this is a
nice generous super check
congratulations fellas it's been a long
journey and glad to have witnessed and
been along for the ride hopefully we'll
catch up soon sometime in celebration
tell us about your favorite reaction
memories of each other
i think my favorite was uh
i got two because you and i did
interstellar and it was the first time
you realized had any interest in that
greg just shut up while i was talking
that's when you were anthony and then i
was that's when i didn't know how to be
like oh [ __ ] i got this like weird pervy
right right personality i don't know how
to be that way around my brother and
then and then
he showed up and then we did
interstellar and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on how does he know so much
about like space
i have no idea what he's talking about
right now you're trying to swim
wormholes to me um what you should have
done is do the whole thing that people
do in movies is like you draw the circle
then you put it in a bowl then you put
pencil through it or something oh but
when you you came on my channel and we
did my name is khan and that was
memorable for me because you like cried
watching that trailer which was like
just crazy to me anything for the views
on the jaby kuwait channel
but uh my favorite experience of
shooting with greg was actually for um
no what's her name uh we shot at youtube
space la with uh
call what my name is what my my my what
my lauren yeah that's right i want my hi
my name is lauren
i want my lauren
because i i was doing some kind of a
voice
and it was like greg was so caught off
guard he just started laughing
hysterically and it was the first time i
saw him laugh like that at me sometimes
sometimes you're so funny you are
something
you broke character you were trying to
stay in character do something you
couldn't do it sometimes you do
something i'm like that was genuinely
hilarious right
quick fact
comedy quick fact in the chat for
midarpus apparently the girl who gives
obi-wan those drugs was ewan's real
daughter
the girl with the pink hair
wow hello there evil wing kinibo
soap tape congrats on 1 million guys
can't wait for 2 mil wait wait wait wait
we got to answer the another view
question
john john favorite react memories ooh
i think
it sounds like i'm talking i'm gonna
talk about me sure i think the one that
came out of me that surprised me the
most
and i know people don't like this show
but the
the third episode of game of thrones
when arya stark stabbed the night king
that
that was so that was like mo when she
stabbed him
and i remember watching it
and then all of a sudden i was just like
screaming at the top of my lungs yeah
and that i had that nervous giggle
afterwards
because
i didn't realize what i just did until
after i did it again i was like i was so
into that i didn't realize i just did
that uh yeah that was uh that was a
really uh cathartic moment and um that
was yeah among the best yeah
and then the show really let me down
after that
what about you john um oh golly there's
let me pick one of many thousand videos
uh
i always enjoy a lot of things including
the esoterica and i think we did some
don't hug me's i'm scared
and
those were delightfully strange and
wacky uh oh god i think my favorite one
is jon's first solo reaction video how
was that when everyone was like why
doesn't john have his own youtube
channel
to answer your questions
what was that movie
uh
what was this because it was a time
where i was like
john and i were not like as partnered up
as we are now and then so what was that
channel now your lover how are lovers
before john wasn't like the you know we
were like hey it's greg and john what's
worse like
a bunch of people no it's like a one
with the plane
next on a plane the planes are like
falling from the sky i remember what the
[ __ ] that movie was into the storm into
the storm into the storm yes with
richard armitage all right going back to
the regular that was a very good guys
for everyone who's been popping in
saying congratulations hi from
albuquerque breaking reactions which has
breaking bad titles says hi from
albuquerque home of breaking bad better
call saul exactly so what are you going
to do to celebrate this this is what
we're doing to celebrate dance we are
doing this that's soap tape is that what
this is the five godzilla clothes you
watch with sally you know miss helena
doing those godzilla things were really
big back now that was very very fun soap
tape dude all right let's keep it going
it's morbid time all right you guys
gotta watch those next stranger things
everybody
as soon as we leave soap tape whenever
you want congrats on one million guys
can't wait for two mil little random but
screw it i always was curious what's
your opinion on evil dead 2013 was uh by
the way i read that wrong uh by the way
more scary videos thanks soap tape john
why do you take that away i'm a big fan
of the evil dead 2013 movie uh you know
there are certain uh you know there are
aspects that could be better but i think
for
what it had to do and uh you know the
legacy it had to uphold i think they did
a really nice job of making it something
lean
very mean like like they shifted the
flavors of evil dead to me like way
toward the the mean and nasty without
losing the essential gleeful humor
behind the camera so i'm a big fan
you know there are aspects
of the dialogue and things that could be
a little shinier and a little more uh
you know punched up but as a take on it
and as just a
mean and nasty version of the movie i
think it's really cool and i think it it
again upholds the spirit by
throwing tons and tons of blood and goo
and nastiness at its actors and uh yeah
i liked what fetty alvarez did there
it's a wonderful watching nasty energy
that's a violent very it's very
entertaining to watch utah very violent
movie thank you john's great with the
vocabulary yeah thousand dollar words do
what i can i'm better at vocab than than
remembering out of large catalogs tyler
james tyler james do you have a p.o box
we do we do
it's available next question uh
if you come over to our patreon you can
find that information or we'll just put
it out there one day yeah but wait we
can we often let that po box pile up and
then we're like we gotta go over there
yeah and i think now we'll probably have
to get a different one and unless we
always want to drive out here
ak yeah
you know what charlie what you should be
the voice that reads that's achara kirk
oh akm my my very own initials thank you
for your super chat uh congrats greg and
john i have watched you guys since 2013.
you got you always have one of the best
reactions mahalo from the big island of
hawaii oh stay safe aloha stay safe out
there from ezra miller yeah twice you
did yeah
what'd you do
i didn't know that what i do in hawaii
yeah i mean were you on vacation were
you doing like stayed at the airport
were you were you there for like a
film at the airport
no nervous
oh i thought you did a thing like when
you went to sweden
no no no no we went to mexico but john
are open to getting an offer today
that's where they're going
james right yeah mexico that's right
morbid time i was like uh i don't want
to hang on any of the mexicans where's
the whitest guy we could find
dead meat james right now and you
meet
jake oh man the freaking mexico is
awesome ashton culture was great that
part of mexico that we stayed at was
[ __ ] beautiful and then every
everyone there who was local was like
just don't go a few miles that way
but over here great oh yeah
if you want to get into trouble real
fast go to topito
uh jaby needs to name his 10 favorite
new rockstars hosts says new rockstars
oh [ __ ] so think about that one oh
that's like legit straight from them too
yeah so the gauntlet has been thrown oh
my god you think about that while i read
this super chat i only know two of them
asked che will you speak with me james
you commented on the post hey debbie
james congrats to them on getting
married ash chase i finally feel like i
can talk with deb me james now because
you got something in common now that
we're at million now i won't feel
intense is he watching right now cause
he's only at four million
yeah we're catching up we got a quarter
of his base you know when you're around
other people with a million subs and you
don't have a million man you just don't
feel like you belong
looking down on you're not even doing
here hold on is he watching right now i
don't think so oh he's got a bigger fish
to fight a story i was gonna tell okay
he's making two thousand dollars right
now with what he's doing he's making
yeah congrats guys i'm for australia i
always watch your movie reviews you guys
are awesome uh keep up the awesome work
that's from ash chase here's ash chase
thank you john read that in your best
australian accent congrats guys hi from
australia i always watch your movie
reviews you guys are awesome keep up the
awesome work very good john
thank you james
that's how i judge you face
red hot
congrats on one million spubs
shout out from the film junkie team and
dave great content thanks man thanks
start the bug film junkie that's a great
channel oh that was a great 101 that
allowed me to express my bvs thoughts is
eric z eric zipper
um
i don't think so i don't think so but
maybe no darth pug chara read your
favorite dog my favorite dog my favorite
book darth park who would win of the
four of
if the four of you went head to head on
trivia movie showdown i would win
last
place yeah and greg would win first
place which means jabilis collabolous
and me will duke it out for the title
for a second i don't know i mean i feel
like you would probably
you uh you you obtain like the most
you're you're like an imdb guy and i'm
more of a specific story guy yeah i feel
like i'll remember detail i'll remember
scenes and stuff really well in in the
character i remember like the movies
well and you will remember like
the production
yeah and the cinematographer on this
video remember like though like you
could name that movie i was telling you
the i already forgot it into the planes
what was it called oh goodness
into the story yeah
yeah evil weather um yeah so second
place so yeah yeah maybe second kung fu
hot dog i like that name a lot what a
great way to wake up in the uk oh my god
achara you read it you're uk reading
your most british accent am i most
british
what a great way to wake up to the at
what in in the uk at
5 11
having some anxiety at the moment but
you guys keep me going great to see the
siblings together it's rare when john
and i are in the same room together yeah
i know
my real brother my real brother over
here brother come here brother
[Music]
don't be anxious look we know nothing
about feeling anxiety i've never felt
anxiety what is that at all times it's a
cowards feeling it's what it is
it's the coward's resting place
no here yeah i think i think i have
anxiety every day the jay shrey way
family one meal finally one mill you
guys are officially morbid with morbid
time all the time
not allowed to be bigger
if i increase it now see that's why we
need you to come here earlier so you can
do obs for us this is how to do all this
that's what happens when i increase it
as well see
i was like i want to go
i want to get it's just scary i want to
get some easiest
congratulations this is awesome tyrone
and jaby may have beaten you to 1
million but you did beat blind wave
here's a question in a life or death
situation would you rather hide in a
ball pit or a haystack what the hell i
would probably want to hide in a ball
pit because it feels like you'd be
easier to breathe than that yeah you can
go like deep into a ball pit and still
breathe
they make it look pretty easy and uh
what do you call it assassin's creed
they make it look really easy to hide in
a ball pit no
just plummeting off of some ancient like
a minaret into a ball pit atara says she
uh
suffocated in a ball pit why because you
swallow a ball no um
i was really young to be fair but it was
my sister's birthday party
and uh so it was at a mcdonald's with a
ball pit and then i just kind of decided
i would go in and like get real deep in
there and then i kind of freaked out
because i was like i don't know which
way is up and which way's down you've
made a lot of sentence words that could
be very suggestive
upside down yeah so you know a character
yeah and then i was like i can't breathe
it's really scary so yeah because of all
the balls that's right too many balls
too many balls i would rather be in a
ball pit hey hey
blind wave is the kings kings of the
reactor the hardest ones to beat i don't
i don't i don't compare our views to you
what about gator
gator martin oh i miss gator martin
the og the og the one who inspired us
all
earl cheese says top reel rejects easter
eggs leave your favorites in the
comments please john says um
after vodka
please do a quick room tour now john you
take that 14k 15 pounds for the
a lot of people always want to get a
room tour it's like the most interesting
part of the room is what you're looking
at already there's a computer and a desk
and and [ __ ] over there two monitors
here there's a batman pail behind one of
them there's a voice modulator mutator
behind that there's a stack of uh
scarlet two channels here there's like
the matrix up in this [ __ ] there's the
other camera it's amazing how clean this
way looks over here is the other
computer right here just looks like
chaos right here is the laptop we do a
lot of [ __ ] on uh you know back there is
a shelf and a window where we get air
sometimes
there's a fan and a closet there you're
gonna fall jab is combined
super michael 98 windows congratulations
guys been watching since godzilla 2014
and this would be like the starting
point for a lot of you guys and the
class when i started i was covering
godzilla
that's when it started really first it
was raid then it was godzilla which one
did you bring mom on for
x-men days of future past oh
that's fun let's revisit that video been
watching since godzilla 2014 and the
classic a million ways to die in the
west
well done 10 million subscribers we're
five where we're at that's not a good
million well million ways to die in the
west is not a good movie what i'm proud
about was that we never pushed for a
billion yeah that would happen to us
like i was aware of it and i was like
well we'll get to a million soon but
i've never been like hey guys get us to
a million subscribers
we've never done that oh you and i was
proud of that i was pretty yeah yeah
tyrone that's a digger you human
[Music]
we've never
we've never done that so i'm proud of
like the people who have subscribed
because then i feel like yeah okay cool
this feels like we earned it in some
ways chris i've been here since the
roast of ryan wright days
keep up the good videos if anyone blew
up it's [ __ ] i'm dante man that guy
was just like this small channel and
then who would roast other channels he
was hilarious where's he now and now
he's like millions of followers and does
like these really popular twitch streams
and his his youtube channel is like
massive
um he's he's [ __ ] great he's great
and a really nice guy too really [ __ ]
nice who's after chris
cross
next up drumroll ilm collectibles
industrial light and magic board you can
go it's okay
jab power
jeez you're making the whole stream
about yourself now you and your boredom
well am i bored and you're bored i seem
bored i see i hate both of us i've been
reading no you do congrats guys for
making it to one million did you already
read it no oh i was like i'm probably
just reading what he just read wanted to
say thanks for everything got me through
some tough times especially with the
wanda vision reviews
special times one division thank you for
sticking with us and i'm glad that we
were able to bring you some joy as a big
big like it's one of those should not
every show even even everybody's into a
personal thing really sure quick take
not even yes it's your chance to char
jump on and do your best greg impression
okay
now you gotta yell at john about being
on a cell phone question yeah one
division though that was not every big
show is like everyone in the world is
watching but that was one of them and i
appreciated it dude you know get your
lumbar uh chilled out you know yeah i
like your two-tone shirt and your teal
pantaloons where are we going with this
uh your uk pants your brewery six
congrats bros i'm kind of late coming
around here watching you since the last
winter been introduced to you uh by my
friend anita
hello anita uh great energy and both
knowledgeable and good critics continue
your good work
enjoy your evening good job
how kind greg you're such a good critic
oh thank you you're a great critic
yeah thank you for the love i appreciate
it you got to make a witty joke now
wit
wit
that's some whip crack wit right there
and that this really does mean a lot i
mean like everything and every uh you
know sentiment that you guys send our
way means a lot but for some reason
being called out as being
decent critics
makes me feel very very lovely because
uh no pressure because that was the the
grain of of of what started the channel
is just our like you know
ability to banter over but also actually
break down a movie and so i'm glad that
translated thank you for the kind words
danger dangerous shoes whopping 50 bucks
in the danger shoes love your videos and
this channel
wish you all the best and continued
awesomeness
that's all right no that's good i want i
like
i liked it it was like we were about to
go to a monster truck rally i can feel
it uh and jules are in the main chat we
all tell the real rejects original
stories we did a monster truck right
two million subscribers uh
we did we went to for uh zombies
zombieland doubletap we uh saw the
gravedigger digger
and we wrote in books
uh so yeah dangerous shoes thank you so
much for you don't want to sit in the
background kindness
all right time to tell you guys some
truth
jennifer armstrong thank you for the
love i want you guys to know this place
[ __ ] sucks
all right
so
we want to move so you have not believed
the amount of crap that we've dealt with
here
right now it's 10 40 p.m
and our water is completely out and we
have no idea why
we have no clue why the water is out
that's just one of many things and i'll
tell you about
living here
and i'm like and that's why i have to
move i have no idea what's going on i'm
just like
what's going and that happens so often
here
and right over there is the laundry unit
that hasn't been working for three
months and uh when they decided three
months and they decided to take off that
laundry when they were like oh we're
gonna do some construction there they
never gave a heads up one day we just
went down there i'm like why isn't the
laundry open mm-hmm and now it's and
they're like oh it'll be done and you'll
be done in a couple weeks like it's been
three
months
yeah done in a handful of weeks in the
what saturday at 10 40 and the water's
out you're off camera a little bit
because it's saturday night man what
would you like no one's going to be home
using their water on saturday everyone's
gonna be out till this place foreign
sucks so much i
can't i can't believe it do you want to
keep reading the move here
the [ __ ] landlord realizes
this this guy
he knows my [ __ ] you better give him
back my [ __ ] deposit i swear to god
xander bro [ __ ] [ __ ] man
yeah
uh there's a there was a generous super
chat you missed where was it where is it
i'll read it i'm sorry dangerous
dangerous shoes thank you
okay
ruining the 1 million subscriber
celebration by turning off our water
jennifer armstrong hello hey you guys
have made the transition out of this
hellish building possible just with your
love and support yeah
thank you very much jennifer armstrong
as well thank you for the love and the
celebration thank you thank you so much
xanadu
if y'all ever reacted to my channel
trailer i think i would cry
y'all are my heroes xander bro you sound
so familiar xander bro i feel like i've
i've seen you once or twice before you
seen you you reacted to the channel
trailer adam from fanpops wow
all four of you inspired my wife and i
to start a reaction channel and i have
to say greg's video with 3c films is
what we always refer back to as the
start must be a huge memory for us as
meeting john and coy on the mom red
carpet cheers to you guys no way
yeah you remember me oh how cool i guess
awesome around for that damn i hope
thank you adam from fan pops damn dude
dude that's
keep it there because chris from 3c
films just messaged me i want to take a
photo of this you're not getting a name
in there
you got his name's not in there i got it
it's adam from fan pops
thank you adam that's crazy yeah
oh my goodness keep up the good work i'm
gonna have to go peruse your channel
some more oh there that was the smarter
thing to do yes because i am smart lathe
jabor
been on since wanda vision y'all helped
me through tough times first super chat
on any channel ever y'all
are a plus can't
for
can't wait for what's to come dude y'all
and koi a plus doesn't mention get
jabbing here what's up with that dude
what's up with that jaby not here enough
no one knows who i am they're like why
is that guy in the middle of the screen
you have a bigger following than koi
they still don't know who i am you have
a much bigger following than koi why
aren't you hosting morbia sweets
uh greg and john you guys are awesome
found you during the no way home hype
and you're now my favorite channel right
random question who is your favorite
star wars character bobo frick
lives
coming back confirmed
oh god uh cgi mark hamill that one do
you have a real favorite character
probably baby yoda
uh
he's pretty great character grogu is
that's a character he's got development
you know yeah you know he's got good
luck
he's got good puppeteering no the the
mike
the guy who's like i've spoken or
whatever he said my favorite star wars
character is dash rendar
no my favorite from the n64 game my
favorites are the power rangers that i
played all the way through the current
the power ranger crew from the
jar jar lollipop where it's look at boba
fett
oh my god what is happening
the power injury book of babu frick
vespas
very best i think uh i think my favorite
one is um
for star wars characters han solo
i was in erin right sadly you feel like
it's like the popular personality ones
like uh han solo and dinjarin are my
favorites
didn't jar really gets me i think what
they pulled off with him is really
impressive to get that emotional i don't
know how you feel about the
mandalorian i love it
do you achara
okay okay good to know
she has an opinion even papa kirk likes
it papa kirk apocalypse
yeah i loved it oh i love that that
[Music]
ray's the best isn't
she cyber character ever
the the promise of finn the hypothetical
promise of faith whatever oscar isaac's
character's name is i think it's i think
it's din jaren is my favorite character
i think man
how they made him so emotionally
invested in him when you couldn't even
see his face yeah and then i think that
got solidified for me when he showed up
in book of boba fett and i was like my
heart just went whoa
oh you must be my favorite character
the ewoks pelimoto palimoto baby noir
thank you for chiming in been here since
ryan wright still owned the channel rest
in peace seriously though very happy the
right is dead he's
is your rap song still up there maybe
it's all coming to an end ryan wright's
last defense yeah i'm byron yo congrats
guys
thanks man
thank you appreciate the water james
birthday rats on being byron massive fan
from nz here uh new zealand to keep up
is it new zealand yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah keep up the amazing work
up the amazing work we can power through
these i got it mr downtown one million
woo your work love it double toasted
sent me here oh double toasted yes i
love double toasted oh double toasted oz
corey martin christian christian
cosmic danielle other chris uh tommy
there we go cindy
cintel
angry max and tiny friends hi hey greg
and john it's rachel hit me out rage
thank you max this is when john was
skipping ahead to get to talk to you on
text messages
on my cell phone all right john you need
to call me on my cell phone
we gotta call rachel
uh rachel thank you for chiming then
thanks you guys that's a generous super
thank you guys for making my day uh by
being yourselves you truly feel like
another side of myself that gets
to express the passion of films i never
discussed in real life congrats on 1
million you guys deserve it thank you so
much i mean
you know it's weird when we hear that
because we grew up in l.a
where like everyone doesn't shut the
[ __ ] up about movies so it's just such a
common thing to talk about but then when
you go to other parts of
in the world like if i go to colorado
i'm like no one really cares about
movies
and so yeah it's actually i take the
community out here for granted and
that's just part of what we do there's
so many people who are into movies out
here and it's just a everyone wants to
be a goddamn film reviewer when you walk
out of a theater
jack attack five been watching the
channel for over a year great content
react content so glad to see you guys
finally reach one million thanks buddy
thank you so much thanks we're happy to
be here i think it means something what
does it mean to be at a million does it
mean anything it's just a number you
feel
it gets so much easier after this
it's like half the work triple pay
thank you jack thank you jack and just
again thank you coda because that that
idea of another side of yourself getting
to talk about the films you don't
usually get to like i feel that and i'm
glad we can do that definitely
charles bronson plays congrats on one
million if you could react to your
spider-man home sweet home short film on
family films youtube channel it would
mean the world to our spider-man home
sweet home i was like confused yes that
one maybe send it our way let's do it uh
flick and reel sorry oh flick it real
jesse jesse swift congratulations from
your friend jesus i didn't even have to
read that to know who you are jesse
fellow quirky merc jesse swift go
subscribe to flick and reel
i'm super chatted again thanks you guys
also great entertainment for a sunday
morning thank your great entertainment
i [ __ ] with jesse's fifth in person
yeah and he cried he came up to me and
he's like greg what's up uh i was so
sincere i was like
hey
uh nice to meet you what's her name he's
like it's jesse
like jessie
he really thought of him recognizing
this is not funny to you because you
don't know just [ __ ] jesse
but to jesse it was hilarious it was
hilarious jeff nicholas
stop sending us money you're gonna get
back
yeah stop making investments in yourself
jeff nicholas nice work y'all uh glad
the heart is still beating it is that's
all it's about it's keeping it beating
the big beat just keeps the beating
heart of the channel going beating heart
uh moochie
yeah we're still going guys what happens
when we decide to go live for an hour
what a nice stream to come home to at 5
30 a.m after a long 12 hour shift four
of my favorite reaction reactors
reactors in one place dude fall asleep
to us oh my god we got it the one in the
chat thank you so much
luanne thank you from antiqua and uh
mango thank you buddy disney fan i
always see you in our comments thank you
for being here gavin glazier
thank you congrats guys i've been here
since old greg if you know what i mean
uh your journey is awesome and you both
have grown so much as people you deserve
this as opposed to the other uh you
deserve the success hopefully we can
meet someday i feel like i'm just
angrier
and more neurotic
and i definitely sexually harass my
employees yes
being one employee hey john yeah sorry
for making a toxic work environment
around here that's okay
i really should smile more and you know
i like it when you slap my ass like
sometimes she's just editing bent over
and i'm just not bam cut that reaction
of john
whoa
yes sir
you're hugging me too long
i'm byron congrats from new zealand
enjoy that million lives for kevin
spacey
no no no no that was pixar's guy uh from
new zealand from uh john leicester
tim allen likes to hug people tim likes
to hug for a long time they're all
perverts at pixar every one of them
can't wait is that why he's not buzz
lightyear again
no that's why they got captain america
instead
tim allen yeah dude thanks i'm byron i'm
byron dude we're gonna enjoy the million
left we're gonna be like why do we need
to upload anymore so we did it we did it
we got to the end there's nothing more
than we'll do i mean we're going to
close the zoo there's more why don't you
guys go because we have to feed the cats
i'm going to close the super chat i'm
getting a lot of anxiety when there's a
people here
there's not some weird excuse i would
tell koi the same thing what are you
trying to say greg i'm saying that
nikoi knows the rules when he comes over
he's like yo you're gonna have to like
stay away from that these cats right now
so
i want the most awkward exit we can
think of unceremoniously
dropped from the live stream
just leave i gotta feed the cats and
they're you guys are spooking them
they were loving it you are distressing
really anxious
what's going on stay for five minutes
that's everything's gonna be an awkward
goodbye
i'm gonna awkwardly transition you guys
out of here
while i close the supercharger i'm so
confused right now john's
super chats
i i thought we're supposed to go watch
stranger things now
do you have to record it tonight
uh i thought
you said to do that that's i was just
listening to you wait are you guys gonna
record stranger things tonight i think
so
how long are you guys usually up
uh lately it's been like three in the
morning and wake up at seven
that's
our lives
well you know that johnny depp thing
takes a long time to edit and then
youtube likes to fight with me and say
that it's not uh friendly for
advertisers and then i gotta wrestle i
wonder why
it's freaking advertiser friendly
yes and i wrestle with them and i'm like
request review and then eventually they
let it go
yes advertiser what are we doing for
five minutes everything nothing we just
how's how have you been enjoying before
jaby goes i want to ask him how would
how are you enjoying this stream
it's the best thing ever no be honest
stream that i've ever participated in
she means that do you mean that a charge
she doesn't like she doesn't like going
live streams you know you don't say the
word [ __ ] enough in this stream
why do i need
do you think
exactly [ __ ] why do you think i have to
say that
i do say [ __ ] i say it's about
relationships i say abroad and how women
are different than men this freaking bro
you guys should check out his
livestreams they're very different
what are you doing to me well what do
you mean by that
wait john are we logged out of the
stream no but it did that thing you know
where you go to a part of your channel
and it's like hey we need to verify that
you're still you
i got too bad don't worry yeah
we're doing this john oh so i'm enjoying
this live stream do it
do it it's just it's so interesting to
see all the love you get do it do it
what does that mean
well i'm just like i don't i does that
mean what i said i'm inter i'm
interviewing you now to know how your
live stream experience went with us
that was very nice i enjoyed it very
much are you sure it's giving me hashtag
goals can you guys subscribe to get jaby
his channel's struggling right now yeah
javis kablab is my jaby is broke and he
could use a couple of well i wouldn't
say i'm broke but i'm not buying a house
yeah i'm you're not just because you're
not willing to put everything you've
earned
into your house
you're not willing to get all the super
chat money ever
into one location
just when i got comfortable they pulled
me back in i've just had such terrible
like okay where you live
the landlord management is not bad i i
asked you not to leave and you said no i
got a good place great manager brandon
hooked me up it's gonna be awesome i
mean this place was fine in the
beginning and then it just have slowly
devolved into like the finale of the
vince gilligan show yeah this was uh
but no you have great landlord and uh
management yeah my car's only gotten
broken into three times it's no big deal
besides we get broken into all the time
so besides nothing seriously they have
no suck it up i know they've noticed
this all the times that they're stealing
like cadillac converters out here in the
parking lots and stuff so yeah this
but the
that place that was like that was good
management and uh every other place i
lived at i'm like man i just hate it so
i was like it's time to own
where the management's the worst yeah
or i'll manage i'll manage my own [ __ ]
from now on start yelling at yourself in
the mirror yeah damn it me no man gotta
get i gotta
you gotta if you can save up to might as
well just do it you know you guys can do
it you're in a better more comfortable
place than me
do you guys wanna get jaby to come back
for i've been trying to figure out a
movie reaction to do with him everything
everywhere all at once no you've already
seen it you've already seen a jab if i
can't do it then you can't do it
i forgot what happens in that movie you
can't forget that movie shelio takes
america chavez
it's a great running sequence
all right
all right you're free to go now okay bye
bye
goodbye good job
well uh before i go
oh you have a gift
no i don't have a gift
um
i don't this is awkward uh so anyway
i've watched you greg struggle up and
down with this youtube thing for for a
long time and
there was actually a moment where i was
like yo greg i got this uh job opening
that you can do
and you're like no i'm going to stick to
the youtube thing and there was actually
this fleeting moment in my heart where i
was worried for you because i was like
greg should take this job i don't know
why he's sticking to this youtube thing
when he should take this job it's paying
really well but greg stuck to his guns
and he stuck to doing youtube and
eventually john became a staple of the
channel with him and here he is at a
million subscribers and he's actually
doing quite well and it was one of those
few instances in my life where i was
like i was wrong
i was wrong i was like i can count them
on one hand i can
no cause i tell a char all the time i'm
like i'm not wrong often but i do
remember when i am wrong and that was an
instance where i was wrong and i was
like i am so glad greg stuck to it and
he's like i can be stubborn too he did
he did offend he's you've done fantastic
work and i'm i'm very proud of you what
was the job
it was uh at a casting studio it was a
coding department no
there was a casting shooter where they
needed just like someone to deal with
computer ships vcrs um but no i'm i'm
proud of my brother who's on his phone
looking at text messages i'm proud of
you i just want you to know that i'm
proud of you i'm proud of both of you
guys for getting this far you guys have
done very very phenomenal work thank you
thank you for letting me be part of this
millions of
did you just fart no my
that that was literally uh a crowd in
the middle of me trying to say something
crack i'm surprised you heard it that
was my crack that means a lot i i
remember that it's when the yellow
dollar bill signs got introduced in
pewdiepie [ __ ] up some people's
channels for a while
and we were like oh no
i'm not making anything anymore
no but you guys are doing great work and
i actually watch it i watch you i
actually watch your stuff like very
frequently because i actually find it
entertaining to watch so yeah man i see
your notification bells man
what's your favorite real rejection
uh i told you earlier it was uncharted
video oh
yeah
i like being on uncharted
john we're in uncharted territories now
so jaby's great kind of comment i hope
you know this john
anyway i'll go home and watch your top
gun uh review satisfying head to touch
you've got a cool haircut i used to want
a haircut like that one your video got
50k in
six hours that's not really right that's
not real time
then what is it in real time
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that that's
not that's a real time it's better than
that
no okay no but seriously for some reason
youtube does not like to tell me my real
time it it's like i look at your stuff
and i'm like i feel like that's closer
to real time than mine uh my real time
right now is uh
a hundred thousand no i don't know
hundred fifty thousand never mind shazam
zafar in the twenty congratulations greg
and john every time i like some movie or
series i come here to see your reaction
to you nice that's not more success to
you okay i appreciate that very much
dude can i borrow some money from your
amber heard videos
i'm gonna need it i got a house
that was a weird experience i was like
i've been following this trial but i
don't want to talk about the trial and
then every time we try talking about it
i'm like i feel weird that we talked
about i want to do this
because it's real it's real [ __ ] hey hey
they're in the room right now we we say
these opinions with their sorry they're
the amber hurts i wish we could just do
what you said
there's a johnny depp amber heard trial
channel
they they have lawyers talk to them on
twitter the johnny depp amber channel
actually they did i saw the lumber guy
talked to me i was like what the hell i
saw man this is unreal which guy the
lumber the lumber guy no more tv show
reactions guys
it's time to only do drama videos now
you'll blow up trial videos just
recently do drama videos man
judge judy here right because
yeah react to low profile cases exactly
all right we got some more things to
wrap up go watch stranger things guys
when that underperforms do more drama
videos
it has been underperforming uh congrats
to all the rejects for being part of the
family
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
you guys are awesome thanks for
following wash my hands this chocolate
remains thanks for following and
supporting my brother and his uh gay
friend
i'm sorry i said that wrong sure i meant
to say
i'm very very pleased i'm often very uh
and happy how does the camera stream
quality look it looks great it looks
that looks better than the other camera
it does look pretty sick on it actually
all don't know how how charming john is
with the ladies
john doesn't have to do anything he just
he just shows up he's nice and puts his
hair down and [ __ ] does amazing
things it's weird
well he has also got those words
thousand dollar words and what john's
good at doing is he's being a good
listener yes he's a good listener like
he looks and he's invested in what
you're saying but when it comes to
talking about himself he doesn't really
do it then he becomes his mystery box
and it creates all problems it's a great
pattern yeah that sounds like
that's exactly actually yeah
and and john john always notices like
he'll always be like oh achara i like
your lipstick today i mean oh my god
like i made an effort thanks for
noticing or he'll be like like today oh
i love your two-tone shirt and you're
like pants combo oh yeah this is the
little dude
guys take notes that'll get you far and
i'm like nice rack
[Music]
you know i'm engaged
wreck
rock
big boobs rack
do people ever think you're dating
does that ever come up yeah
yeah
no no it doesn't really exude that way
it was like brohomo jokes we get that
all the time i don't know why have you
heard the lonely ion song no homo it's
very funny all right guys go home okay
bye bye get out of here while we go home
after being here we're gonna wrap this
in also
uh somebody called me wanted to charge
to know that they love achara
hey char is great she's a sweetheart
with a weird sense of humor really dry
humor
i don't think anthony appreciates her
humor enough no she's awesome dude
people in the chat are literally rooting
for you to leave this condo
jules r said we'll be happy when you're
finally out of there
all right
she doesn't mean that yes she does she
knows she knows i've been watching the
whole stream all right i'm turning your
mic off no one said anything mean turn
that [ __ ] mic off now that he's
finally going jesus christ
jabby mike is doused go go
i love you guys make jam make john
chamber
jamboree
jamboree
thanks y'all for supporting my brother
and his best friend thank you all for
being here thanks jaby and charles for
being my best friend's brother
thank you guys
thanks for being my best friend's
brother
thank you guys
for showing up whoo
all right now we can understand i'm
gonna make this stream we really wanted
it it can be in full effect all right
hit that end stream button
of course all right let's get through
the last of these we turned off the
super chats right super chat's turned
off all right here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do the last of the chats and
stream labs and we're just gonna engage
with the real chat for a while yeah
all right the real truck
congrats greg and john where are you
gonna put the new play button uh we
answered that question already john
uh-oh yep so it's nerdy chronicle no
more from you
chronic all right oh we did bella all
right cool
wait wait no we didn't do that bellow
one hahaha bella bella bella he doesn't
love you he doesn't love you
i think the stream quality looks better
than the other camera hey
do you think so yeah it does look very
clean it looks actually clean
yeah well guys we gotta work on the
stranger things videos to get to you
guys but uh congrats great john and greg
very deserved jabby no we did that one
all right
congrats on one million guys super proud
to have been a small part of the journey
you've been a very instrumental part we
learned a lot from our experience with
you and you helped us get through some
really tough edits for a very long time
and unable to get a lot of that [ __ ]
they hated all of our snyder cut
reactions yeah
and uh and a whole bunch of other ones
too a bunch of stuff but even more
inspired by your hard work and
dedication please say happy birthday to
you happy birthday drew it's drew's
birthday today oh drew happy birthday to
drew
happy birthday to drew
happy birthday dear drew grant
happy birthday to you
[Music]
and many in addition to those well
wishes that we just sang to you
hey react to indian stuff more you got
it
rr coming your way right
boom jessica
cohen and rejects after dark we've had a
lot more
uh lady presence in the chat than usual
that's right man than ever usually it's
just one than ever before it's just the
one lady there's just one lady it's just
the one it's nice when the female
demographic goes up turns up for for
turn down for what here john kevin
shepard hey y'all john's gonna read this
one hey y'all been watching for about
seven years now so since early high
school just graduated from college
jeepers jesus congratulations dude i
hope you have no debt and i hear that
once you graduate from college job right
away walk in there job and you're set
for life pay off all debts good luck get
you the keys to a house and a company
car yeah good uh just graduated from
college first vid was either shia
labeouf cannibal song or don't hug me
i'm scared nice appreciate your work
keep going would love some coverage of
indie stuff yeah more requests for more
indie stuff i love indie and indian
stuff indie indian movies i mean i think
we know you know some people would say
like all we cover is like the big
franchise stuff which i know that's like
the main stuff that we i generally do
but i feel like when we branch out like
with experimenting with things
or or something a little bit against
like superhero content is usually with
the movie reactions and stuff
white chicks you do white chicks man
little independent comedy we didn't know
buddy we did nobody is is kind of an
independent movie i mean yeah by
universal studios
low budget and independent are two
different things that's why i want to do
everything everywhere all at once first
movie reactions that we did were like i
did mid samara we did willie's
wonderland you know like
i think weirdly the movie reactions uh
are are some of the most fun i think to
implement on the channel the show all
right john while you're loading that
i'll go through the chat here don't you
worry my friend let's get some chats get
some chats are people still here
uh let's see let's check those numbers
let's check the numbers damn we have put
this person on timeout huh yeah do it do
it to it yeah we got over a thousand
peeps in the chat
we've got over a thousand people here
now
be here now mindfulness i think we were
one of the first people someone frank
dude says i was looking for people who
react to new rock stars i think we were
the first people to start reacting to
rock stars dude and then everyone reacts
to new rock stars now and hey i mean
back in the day i remember you having
the bright idea to start titling
reaction and review and really emphasize
honing in on the fact that it's not only
reacting it's breaking down i don't know
if you guys remember the days
when there was like grade a under a and
then the channels hating reaction
channels and that was like a really
tough period
where they were like all people do is
react and then say subscribe afterwards
and i was like oh my god we gotta up the
content it's to really stand out right
it's not working no one notices when we
do more than just
no one stays around that's their fault
so like when we have videos that pop off
that are just like reviews or um
that's why the tv reactions and movie
reactions are fun because they require
you can see that those
take good amount of time to put together
and so i'm proud i'm proud of that's why
i'm pretty proud of what the channels
become the last couple of years i'm not
gonna lie i think i think in the past
couple years i'm really proud of what
what we've been able to to do
hey babe i think anthony left
all right let's see we're so close uh
congrats from new zealand enjoy that
million dollar million
you guys were reacting before reacting
were cool
yeah man you you you trialled by fire a
lot of that stuff
you guys are erected the true uh tragedy
macbeth no we haven't
no i'd be curious to see it i've heard
i've heard i mean it's very striking
i've heard it's beautiful to look at i
am pumped for gray man oh we got these
loaded somewhere ready so i think we are
back in action here dasha always
watching do a reaction for your channel
jason c found you guys from movie fights
congrats hey
dude you have some impressive go watch
greg's movie fights because they are
things of beauty in the next stage of
the real rejects maybe totally frank
with you guys is i'm trying to help
really elevate other people now
so it means
elevate more john
and then now that's why we're getting
coy and sally i want to really help
elevate other people now i was like all
right we're here at the first million
cool
i got to lead the ship here now it's
time to really elevate other people
that's like the main
next step that i'm like really focused
on
is just bringing up others right now and
seeing what you can do when you're like
okay this channel is making uh money
currently and then i've always liked the
idea of having a channel where i can
employ people that i really like
and that are my friends and i'm like
that'd be that'd be pretty cool to be
able to do that for people that's the
dream that is like a big step that is
literally like you cannot believe the
hours and hours and hours of
conversations i've had
to make to get that to be the next step
of like what
how much do we need to set aside a month
so we can get these people going and pay
so it's been a big that's like that is
like the next big thing that i want to
do is trend transition some of these
people on here a little more often so
when koi's video
last week did so well
i was so happy about that i was so
thrilled that it like to get 70k on a
video that has not not myself nor jon in
the thumbnail
and it's not like a reaction to just be
a like a theory video yeah it was like
oh [ __ ] this is really cool i'm really
and i was just so happy for koi and i'm
like i want to do this regularly this
would be really good for him so
yeah that's like the next step um
yeah sharing the well and then john will
do a nicholas cage movie reactions once
a week by himself
where i react to all the nicholas cage
movies
while doing a nicholas cage
that's the next big thing
oh like the place that i just got is is
is gonna be two minutes away from where
he lives
and ten minutes away from where koi
lives whereas now it can be up to like
40 minutes for john and sometimes up to
an hour for koi sometimes an hour and a
half for koi because of where i live now
this [ __ ] anywhere the drive is anywhere
from 12 to 40 feet no it's weird it
can't be that way
so um yeah like where i'm living now
where i'm gonna be moving to like a big
part of that is making it easier for
them to come by like i really wanted a
good location to make it easier for them
to come by and so
no wait like
this is the first year i can confidently
say like no i actually have like real
plans for where i want to take the
channel there's like real plans in mind
not just like oh well super how it goes
like actual real ideas that have been
implemented so it's just all about
slowly introducing stuff as opposed to
throwing it all at you like we're some
[ __ ] network
an intent
gradual build
eldos maita mata matai sorry congrats
guys glad to be a reject we're glad to
have you as a reject heart
thank you so much thanks buddy
pikachu
congrats on the milestone guys watching
since loki it's a good ass series love
you guys love the show love the
a chaby cameo
waiting for more stranger things for
well you shall have what you seek i'm
gonna put i'm gonna put up three and
four tomorrow um i don't know if it's a
good idea to upload to
it's always the thing with algorithm
that you always wonder is like should i
spread these out more or should i just
upload them now if like if people only
wanna watch four they're gonna watch the
read
you just try to figure that [ __ ] out but
are we spoiling you or are we just
giving you an excuse to skip ahead are
we hurting are we hurting the views that
we can get from this there's always a
question mark about these things
uh but i was like i know let's suppose
three and four because we got the boys
coming up this week yeah and we got
obi-wan that's been moved so i was like
we just gotta like get these out right
now because i'm we're also i gotta move
um everything's happening right now
angry max and tiny friends rachel uh if
you call again we will answer
now we had too much chaos over here
before yeah call again and we'll say
what's up because uh yeah it's it's way
more manageable with just the two of us
joe snapha john should start a tech
support channel i'd watch it i my tech
support i appreciate that my tech
support channel would be very marge
simpson though it would be like okay i
gotta stay one lesson ahead of every
video
to make it seem as though i know and
really i'm just youtubing other things
to help me figure out how to do all this
but i appreciate
that vote of confidence part of me has
considered doing silly tech reviews on
instagram or something like that
uh oh hey
rachel
oh my gosh hey rachel what's up you're
not a you're not a person it's been
years rachel it's been years you're not
on the video but but we're showing the
phone screen so people can tell who you
are
okay i'll pause because i'm also
watching it on youtube and there's a lag
yeah turn down your radio
god what were the videos we did
i know you and i did some game of
thrones and didn't you guys do some
reactions together too
we did a
kinky porn reaction
porn reaction
um like a movie that greg's friend from
elementary school i guess was in uh
where it was like a guy who had like
psychic towers or something
holy crap i don't know
anyways that's that's like
i mean a lot of deleted videos and we
also did a um reasons to see
yeah for uh hunger games or
oh
hobbit that's what it was yeah
yeah
wizard of oz
one of the best
yeah ozzy great and powerful wow thanks
for calling us rachel yeah thank you we
can't really get the audio in the
microphone unfortunately but thank you
yeah i'm doing my best here but
this is yeah
for helping us feel special
oh yeah no problem i just want to say
like congratulations on your one million
subscribers and uh i was in japan for
seven years uh so i'm just waiting that
i couldn't be there for most of it it's
all i mean you were in japan which is
freaking amazing which is awesome and
you were enlightening you were shaping
young minds out there so
much
yeah but um i'm here until july 17th so
if you want me to uh react to whatever
i'll be happy to help you again and also
just congrats and i'm really proud of
both of you every time i see you on my
feed i'm i'm just so ecstatic like oh my
god they did it
you know they accomplished yeah yeah
well thank you rachel thank you
appreciate you we'll have to talk some
more we we gotta we gotta keep the we
got to keep honoring the people who have
who have chipped in yeah i i really wish
this was like not a planned live stream
at all otherwise we would be like sit
down stay awhile yeah
but um yeah all right uh keep keep in
touch i'm so proud of you and i'm so
like in awe of everything you've
accomplished and i'm so like humbled or
uh not humbled what's the word i'm i'm
so happy to have like been there since
the beginning yeah
thank you rachel thank you never forget
those days yeah man the old improv crew
yeah
well here hear hugs and loves and we'll
talk soon okay
okay thank you i'll shoot you a message
after the stream's done oh thank you
yeah
of course all right bye
was random
friends coming by thanks rachel thank
you rachel
i do feel bad but we gotta we gotta keep
people we gotta keep the people pleased
that's how we got here in the first
place jon snapper thank you the
initiative hi guys carlos here what's up
carlos first fan to recognize you in
public
so proud of how far you've come so
excited for you guys 1 million
subscribers
you know what's funny carlos you never
you don't ever have to say what your
name is i'll never forget your name ah i
have people will sometimes ask me like
do you remember the first time someone
recognized you yeah a guy named carlos
sit down let me tell you
carlos i remember i i will never forget
that that was that was a a
a very unusual day i was there with
lauren god marie day we were there to
watch x-men days of future past at
arclight theaters in pasadena
and um you i i was looking at a funko
pop that they had there and i looked to
my right and then i see carlos
with i see this guy this kid is that's
like his his jaw dropped
like that it was like really expression
and
this is l.a
so i was like
ah this is jason stacey
no i thought it was like no i didn't
think it was that thought it was
actually like it's one of those crazy
guys from l.a it's like a crazy guy
and then
that's what i thought i thought i was
just some crazy guy from l.a yeah sure
yeah and uh because he's just like
staring at me like that and he was right
and he's like you're ryan right and i
was like i turned to marie and lauren i
was like oh [ __ ] this guy recognizes us
and then
yeah i'll never forget that that was the
first i'll never forget the first time
getting recognized that was a that was a
highlight yeah shouts out to marie and
uh and lauren and shouts out to my dude
aaron from dank ass stubs too all the
all the fellow [ __ ] aaron man come
through
uh hey joe snaffer was just thinking
back thank you also for chiming back in
was just thinking back to your split
trailer reaction where greg did a ton of
impressions and accents back to back
after hearings john's impressions on
this stream he needs to do the same i
know i gotta i gotta get my i got a grip
i gotta get a grip on all my impressions
so that when someone requests i can just
do them and not have to go damn i need
to watch them again so i can get the
cadence or just in your head a little
bit yeah probably when you're not on
your head you can easily do it yeah
christopher
when i'm not
when i'm not in my head
it's crazy
hey s jackses 30 thank you for i think
that maybe says support i'm not sure uh
victory victory thank you thank you this
is this is our victory lap cam and zay
congratulations wish jaby
and achara the same fortune well they're
gone now so it doesn't thank you it
doesn't get there yet [ __ ] them all four
of you have been absolutely huge
inspirations especially for my buddy and
i who created our own reaction channel
thank you so much hell yeah dude i
assume that
you must be cam or zay and cam
is your buddy so both of you keep it up
all these reactors coming up here
thinking they can just create a channel
it's easy to just point and shoot easy
as it looks is it something sometimes it
can be but most of the time
have you wept openly at 4 30 in the
morning
have you woken up bright and early for a
trailer that never dropped on my nose
online
despite thousands of reports of people
saying it on the trending page you
research for hours to
know everything you can about a
franchise property only for the trailer
to never come
and the movie did not incorporate any of
what you learned have you spent hours
editing only to get blocked or copyright
claimed
throwing time down a hole and you don't
know what reacting's like you don't know
the life king tannic congrats boys been
watching since transformers 4 trailer
you all deserve this
especially for sitting through that
transformers 4 trailer i remember you
tried doing some solo videos back then
first reviews in my car first
impressions
and you did transformers forward
remember what that was yeah it was me
yelling at just about how it's two hours
and 40 45 minutes
yeah that's that was i was really vexed
by that
there's no excuse for those movies to be
nearly three hours long
this is
terence redmond wow one million
subscribers i was here back during the
ryan wright days and it's amazing to see
you grow and evolve like pokemon
congratulations
hey watson hey white spots people have
been begging to see the cats on the
screen so if you can pick them up you
know oh yeah people have been like take
us on a tour of the cats no these cats
are amazing yeah i love these all four
of these cats are mensches in their own
ways
it's fun having four cats in the office
i tell you what
[ __ ] oh watson bots
want some butts and oh i know
you want to talk in the morning scared
of the microphone why because he doesn't
know what it is it's foreign it's okay
buddy he's foreign
oh well there you go that's the cat that
was my cat from hell x-men for all right
now i can pick him up dude that jackson
got it's all jackson galaxy he really
worked with i was on my cat from hell
okay i'm gonna tell you guys a little
story about being my cat from hell if
you guys haven't seen this animal planet
show
the jackson galaxy takes the cat from
hell and you gotta learn to work with
his methods and stuff so that way you
can develop a relation with the cat so
that kind of just picked up used to
attack me all the time it's like vicious
attacks like sometimes there's one for
lucky for them for their [ __ ] reality
show
i got attacked once with on camera and
it was like the worst it hurt to walk it
was weird i've never had that before
and um
now it's been like over a year and and
we're like best buds
always cuddling kissing him on the mouth
he hasn't attacked me in a long time
he's come a long way he's sweetie but i
remember being on that show
and
i was telling olivia like
don't
because i only wanted it for the for the
cats stuff that all the toys and stuff
on the cat's trees and everything i
wanted all the goodies yeah and i was
like i want to learn how to [ __ ] get
along with the cat and i want to get
along with cat because he keeps
attacking me
and uh
i remember telling olivia like she would
get upset about things and i'd be like
don't show it because you're gonna
[ __ ] put it in the show so just don't
show it don't show it
and then it hit me on one day
because it's called my cat from hell so
obviously the narrative is like [ __ ]
crazy scary cats
and and then um when when we were
filming it because it was a coveted uh
edition they had to do
we had to use um
film it all ourselves basically it was
different for the show as opposed to
like having a whole camera crew in your
house
and they wanted me to follow watson and
then he was hiding somewhere not [ __ ]
after me again right now
and he was and that it was he was hiding
somewhere
and you know because they want to paint
the narrative of like uh how many times
he's like how many times does he attack
you how vicious is he he did it you know
really sits
um
and then to have to follow him into the
closet and he was scared
like he was hiding
and and then it like hit me in that
moment that he's not it's not that he
gets mad and wants to hurt you it's that
he gets scared and he wants to defend
himself that's why he attacks because
he's scared and so when i learned that
when i saw that that just like started
breaking me and i started crying and i
was like don't put the camera on me
because i don't want them they're going
to use the footage i don't want them to
use it then i had to do a post interview
talking about what i learned and i just
started crying
then sure enough
those [ __ ] and animal planet sure
enough yeah
every commercial threat
every commercial break was me crying
coming up you're gonna want to see this
[ __ ] that wasn't it coming up and just
me balling this dude's gonna [ __ ]
break and i was like i knew it i knew i
shouldn't have cried i shouldn't have
done it i was like this is what i was
telling you not to show your emotions
because
they're going to use it
dude jackson galaxy he trained you
yeah
oh goodness thank you terence redmond
x-men forever
8-2-9-0 congratulations on a million
guys thank you so much appreciate you
very much i'm gonna see who this is one
second hello
hello
[ __ ] prank callers man frank's s
jacks30 that's the moment thank you
valentine's x-jacks thank you called to
leave the silence thank you
jake mate
love your guys videos big
lovely guys videos big fan from
australia
oh
let's print the screen let's print the
uh super chats out and then go
out look with these guys
today this isn't that very kind of let's
get a mid-80s printer and just let it do
its thing
making all those nasty ass noises all
right we're gonna scroll back down this
is a good reminder of how far we have to
go
[Laughter]
oh yes
hey because i would do this tonight or
do it in the morning
both zoom i'd rather be up late tonight
prepping stranger things than wake up i
i need to get some sleep i think we
should get i think both you and i need
some sleep and then so and i gotta start
packing tomorrow i think we've gone the
the the maximum amount of days with like
okay i think i'll be able to know
there's something else coming up all
right we're good but hey we got all the
stranger things shot so yeah i mean as
as kooky as this week has been it's been
actually pretty
smooth on certain fronts what's funny is
is like i'm not tired and
when i'm filming but when i'm not what's
up
all right let's get to it uh zoom greg
when will you react to dark and jabby
when is season two jaby uh is gonna put
up all of season two tomorrow i don't
know if we'll ever react to dark i hear
good things about it but i'm not sure if
we'll ever do it it's grown a lot i mean
i remember when it came out and then in
recent i've been like oh damn like
people really seem to like this show and
it seems to actually be like you know
growing in its like you know pop culture
status but yeah i don't know much of
anything about it you know it's isn't it
in german i think so
i guess i i don't currently have an
interest in it and
i would only do it just because i hear
it's popular but not because i have an
interest in it
but i think i feel like it has to be
something where no we're we're genuinely
interested in covering this right now
yeah um more than just because it's
popular you know but who knows like we
didn't cover stranger things so stranger
things season three you know yeah true
so true that cavs baby congrats
you both have inspired me to want to do
reactions i want to be you when i grow
up oh cows he is 45 years old this cast
someday and when you are you can react i
mean you're reacting all day every day
that's what life is all right is
reactions
all right and actions
and reactions to actions and then
actions based on those reactions to
actions the notes i give people whenever
they come over the bane basic note like
with ace so who was just on obi-wan yeah
he's never done videos with us because i
was like oh man i'm kind of throwing you
into like a really long video to do with
us yeah
his like uh
is i don't want to over complicate
things for you so i'm like just don't
talk over when people in the video were
talking that's the first thing
and
whatever you're feeling internally
let it out and express it you know
you're react you're doing a reaction so
so this is the playground to allow
yourself to show what you're feeling on
the inside scream and shout and let it
all out yeah oh we oh weeo
great trailer like it's yeah
hey i i hope you grow up though
yeah
be be well on your journey thunder vibe
okay now that it's 1 million time for a
crossover genius greg cross over with
archer pie
a char a charpie oh jabby a char okay
and i am stunt dude jaby combined with
the 90s john wick john
we don't know these references these are
so deep
cut combos i want whatever this is
though we don't know what you're talking
about
i'm happy to understand this just let us
know but uh
i'll i'll fight stunt dude jaby with uh
my 90s john wick glasses sure
get a clue
we will been a proud sub since your old
alias days when you were just reviewing
trailers back in 2013 so happy for you
guys on the one million good luck for
the future and keep expanding thank you
get a clue we will keep expanding
always expanding
we are the blob
mike k congrats on hitting one uh the
million subscriber milestone thank you
very much mike k
uh thank you my k
mmogib m magib
thank you for the moment of silence
hyperdroid congratulations you two you
two absolutely deserve it and it's been
cool watching you two grow up yet stay
the same in a good way been watching for
ages and hope everyone in the room's
doing good it's just us two now and
is
watson
no uh yes yes he's on the trash can by
the window
he's just here
he's just contemplatively looking over
his city
gotham
courtyard city
[Laughter]
yeah dude watson would be a great uh
vigilante protector of the night dave
where are you
one sec look at watson
look at watson babe
hey jessica cowan says my uh favorite
star wars character is sleeze baggio
who's the guy who sells death sticks to
obi-wan that's a great star wars name
for a skeevy character my name's sleeze
and baggio kind of sounds like baracho
so you know drunken that's good calcus
best star ear best star ears character
yes definitely cow cast is best our ears
who's got the best ears in star wars
thank you janice garrett
said janiece
janiece is that you
is is your username
spelled slightly differently than your
regular name is that eugenice
sending love to you if it is you
anyway welcome back fund me productions
who do i miss eight years hyperdroid
thank you hyperdrive oh yeah funny
production oh you found me back in the
chat thank you buddy eight year
subscriber guys massive congrats thank
you for sticking with us really
appreciate you it's nice to see some
good short films man yeah it's always
really nice to see your name pop up
another view once more hey hey hey hey
hi hi
it indeed is that moment so what a
journey it has been congratulations
again let's catch up soon as for my
question what has been your favorite
sketch to make for the channel
the favorite one to make like the one
that was most fun
you guys have no idea making the
sketches always turns into a
surprisingly stressful experience yeah
they're always stressful because it's
john and i doing like every job
and inevitably each sketch requires we
figure out something we haven't done
before so there's always that element of
like we're not just using what we know
it's also like we're gonna figure this
[ __ ] out and i gotta like
we gotta like usually it's like i'm
like usually main main person directing
and editing it in my head as we're
filming it yes
and i usually beat them out while john
does um everything else
so
yeah and and uh
they can be rough they can often be like
that's why we don't do them too often
because they tend to be struck because
we're always like on a time crunch and
we're kind of rushing yeah yeah and and
um
and i don't want to be stuck editing
forever because it's like the the one
i'll never forget is the spider-man no
way home sketch where i had like eric
boss come in and three c films and heavy
spoilers cosmic wonder
um
like just getting them on board was a
little rough and then
not that rough them all of them said yes
actually but you know she's gonna like
gotta hunt them down for footage and
then
and then um
and then
editing that though that took me like
that took like almost 50 hours to put
together it doesn't look like it but it
that took me like almost 50 hours in
total to put together
and that's why i'm like we don't i don't
have 50 hours
to edit these videos so
that's where we want to do them too most
don't take that long i want to make that
clear most don't that was probably the
longest i know the real read the one
where we did a full-on sketch for the
theater the live event that was that one
took a long time
i had to edit a section and then i did
it most of it i had you added a very
specific section too yeah like that was
really time consuming yes um and that
one has some tricky [ __ ] to figure we
always like them when they're done we
like them and we like watching them when
they're done but the process of putting
them together it's rather like yeah it's
a fun time
it's like no we're pretty stressed out
the whole
that classic thing of like no matter how
no matter they do become like true art
projects in the sense that you start out
and you're like oh this is gonna be
funny we got a fun idea you know and
we're just like we're doing it rock and
roll we're just like kind of guerrilla
shooting and then you do get to that
point where you're like [ __ ] i don't
know if it's gonna work yeah every time
sorry does this suck
and then it comes back around finally on
the other side and you're like i think
it's pretty funny i think this is pretty
fun but also i'm exhausted yeah yeah we
usually are on crunch time get it done
so that's why yeah red sparrow a moment
of silence thank you very much as well
as a question who is y'all's favorite
superhero not yet in movies or
television uh
i know nightwing's on titans but i'm
waiting for nightwing to come out in in
cinema i think they should do a proper
nightwing movie that'd be cool
something that the most in development
thing in the world
i think jubilee should be a good x-men
character one day but i don't really
know too many characters uh
so i think if there's any graphic novels
i've read that have not yet been adapted
yeah
right
there's one i read called torso which is
like elliot ness you know untouchables
kevin costner's character everybody's a
real life person but elliott ness and uh
as a murder mystery one i thought that
was a great one it's not a superhero but
it would be a cool adaptation i think
they sold the film rights to it but they
never actually made it and i thought
that was a that's a pretty sweet comic
yeah
man spider for john man spider for me or
man bat or the batman who laughs
[Laughter]
just any of the [ __ ] up versions of
your favorite characters there's a dc
character i i think has a pretty cool
kind of story and and macabre uh motif
called spectre which i think would be
cool or if i was given carte blanche to
just adapt something i would probably
reach for that um but yeah
uh
here we go moving forward fernando
marchand
thank you for the super sticker
anthony says i meant to make a joke
saying you love her life partner and it
came out as me calling john gay i feel
super bad please let him know i wasn't
making a joke at his expense i was
trying to add to the joke you made
earlier oh
well good this really assuages some deep
seating i'm glad i'm glad he's saying
i'm glad he texted me because
i did not have to refresh my memory on
what he was talking about you should
have seen when you walked them out i was
just talking everybody here being like
i've never heard jaby be such a
homophobic to me what did i do to him
what did i do to deserve this
attack
no i it's it's it's cool thank you jaby
i appreciate knowing exactly what you
meant to say this time
uh but yes man spider here we go
righteous robb congrats boys and
remember
it's morbid time it's always morbid what
is this morbid thing it's just more
morbius
where did this come from is this is this
because of like the morbius thing being
like announced and how popular
it got like a lot of this
there's like this really popular twitch
stream where someone just streamed all
of morbius
morbius has become a cultural meme and i
think
like i saw a meme i've seen a meme
circulating around and i can't verbatim
repeat it because i don't i'd have to go
look it up but it's it's something about
like you know it's one of those memes
trying to make morbius seem like a much
more badass experience than it actually
is and then somebody you know i don't
know basically being like my favorite
part is when he looks at the camera and
goes it's morbid time
just you know oh yeah yeah i saw that oh
i know you're talking about people
talking i think
yeah there have been people pitching
like what the sequel could be yeah yeah
yeah yeah or there's another one i loved
that was like the top panel shows the
batman just a clip still from the batman
and it says like the kids had their fun
this weekend and there's just a picture
of morbius underneath it and it's like
now the adults get their movie like sure
why not
uh but yes it's morbid time all the time
green light that sequel please frank dx
frank dix
congratulations guys
so proud of you been here since 2015 age
of ultron love your content by the way
greg and john you guys considering doing
scott pilgrim versus the world reaction
john knows that movie way too well we
i mean i feel like i've seen it once oh
you've only seen it once well then you
can do it i mean i haven't seen it i
have a very unpopular opinion
i just think it's
fine
you know that is the most important
great reason to go and react again
because maybe you'll like it more i
don't or less dislike it
i remember being like i really like the
visuals and the aesthetic
but the story itself i'm like
it's fine it's fine
yeah
two and a half
i have a pretty unpopular opinion when
it comes to scott pilgrim vs the world
that is like
i like seeing when i when it's like when
watching the miss marvel trailer and i'm
like oh there's like scott pokemon
versus the world vibes that actually
excites me when i see it yet my actual
experience with the with the scott
pilgrim versus the world
i don't get that ex i don't i don't like
it as much as
i do remember the first time a fight
scene happened in that and being like
what the [ __ ] this is like crazy
choreography because it happened so late
in the movie it is one of the movies i
feel like regardless of that because
it's a fair opinion uh but i do think it
is
even though it's technically like
graphic novel i feel like it's one of
the better anime
things approaching anime in terms of
action live definitely translation even
though it pulls more from video games
and and
not not as much manga comics but anyhow
for sure still do that redux cui 22
thank you for the sticker is that a
little super lemon head or something
either way it's delightful and i like it
sahil pal have greg and john watch dark
yet if not do watch it and don't see
jaby's reaction videos on how to go
about it
we should copy exactly what he does to
the point where we're repeating the same
like comments and riffs and things like
that and put it up on april fools that
would be good that would be really good
to read just like get it like uncanny
with the timing like an exact copy of
their reaction
tariq dingle
great last name congrats y'all love what
y'all do and keep making the movie
entertainment space a better place thank
you i'm glad you enjoy what we do and i
appreciate the uh the love
that you've sent
we like to make things better feel
better
thank you thank you
lambie
thank you tarik you've seen your name
a couple times
yo i have been here since around 2015 or
so just since you guys have 1 million
subscribers congratulations dude thank
you notice that good time especially
when we're doing a live stream
specifically about you noticed right
when it happened you know i logged on
this and i just noticed i just noticed
this
just happened
thank you for keeping a watchful eye kai
love you guys congrats on one million
i've been watching since 2019 thanks for
authentic funny knowledgeable reactions
we do
we do make the effort to be
knowledgeable
we do
us but if we don't have time
koi is the escape hatch
i was like don't know if we're gonna get
quite from moon night i better start
reading a bunch of moonlight yes
it paid off
it always pays off but it's also helpful
to have those people come and fill in
only if it's like an actual uh
you know intellectual property franchise
that is definitely has a fan base
already i think that really helps yeah
like for squeezy like admittedly i only
watch clone wars not because i was
actually interested in clone wars but we
watched mandalorian season one and i was
like
we don't know
we don't know enough what's that saber
what does i assume everyone freaking out
about yeah other than i've never seen a
black one before yeah i had no idea what
it was yeah and then uh i was like
america watch columbus i watched clone
wars and i watched most of rebels i did
skip around with rebels but i got the
main story there's
only like a few episodes i haven't seen
in rebels
um
but yeah like that's what i mean by to
make the effort to become more
knowledgeable a lot of the time you know
and so it right up on a lot of obi-wan i
didn't know about um before watching the
show which i thought was cool to
get familiar with or even stranger
things hadn't seen it since season three
came out so i was like let me rewatch
stranger things before recording this so
we do make a concerted effort
absolutely i think we i think we make an
effort to be knowledge before i wouldn't
say that but i think in the past couple
of years we've made the extra mile to
like we should definitely do some reason
we should learn more
everything we're going to be spending
that time on we got to do some research
got to get familiar yeah yeah we need to
make the you are you are better you are
more comprehensive certainly than i am
but you have certainly inspired me to
keep on that and to take just i don't
know it's enriching it's it's
it enhances the enjoyment oh it makes it
way more enjoyable i think and
especially too like even with star wars
like you know to get ready for everyone
like i've been listening to some of like
the books and things like that it's it's
it's stuff i never would have imagined
getting into without this stuff which
you know in some ways you could go like
uh fake but i don't know it's it's fun
to
experience some of those things for the
first time too and kind of see further
and further what other people see
so uh yeah and then there are some
things where you just kind of know
you just know stuff like a lot of times
if it's like horror thing i'll be like
i'm just gonna assume john knows
and i'll just gladly be like i don't
know yeah or if it's like mission
impossible it's like oh yeah it's like
we've seen all those and i know you know
those like the background okay a lot of
the time it has to just be one of us
knows yeah if it was both of us like for
chip and dale i was like i don't know
trimmingdale at all but john's
trippingtail i don't know if we either
of us need to know chippendale yeah yeah
but at least one of us knows yeah
there's always i feel like that's always
a good dynamic is is experienced person
and uh interested noob yeah is always a
good back and forth uh that
uh yes blind jedi
yeah big congratulations to you all
here's your next million and more great
videos
thanks next million
not necessarily going to be great videos
though no no no time to half-ass it
here's the next million based off of
mediocre videos we want people to be
like what happened to you guys well i
mean your hands on two million but how
did you get it you lost your mojo yeah
your quality went down
i saw that once they hit a million man
they sell out so now they lost the
passion
they lost the passion for what they do
take it back to the hunger days the
shame oh the silver guy thank you for a
moment of filipino silence yeah pinoy
pride
[Music]
have you guys watched the trailer for
olivia wilde's don't worry darling very
different from books part but looks
really good oh with harry styles no you
see those those are the kind of movies
i'm like i would like to react to that
movie yeah
uh on the channel
two two dudes i assume you'll bring on a
female guest for that movie you gotta
bring on somebody who who's like gaga
for harry styles
coy
coy is very gaga for harry styles
uh but i have a forrest gump reaction uh
that's just been in the video manager
i've never seen forrest gump up until
recently that's edited just needs a
thumbnail
and uh good day to post it and a good
day to post it and also maybe an ad
maybe nah i mean it's already uploaded
so i'm just like wait for that copyright
claim to get reviewed to go away because
there's a lot of music in that movie
but uh no that that uh that one you know
like doing [ __ ] like that i think is
really fun to have to have in this
random ver what's it like i'm gonna put
up four scum
well a lot of stuff is like sonic the
hedgehog it's superheroes yeah
but every now and again it's just cinema
raise the world project now
congratulations guys roger here you
inspired us to switch to spiritual
reaction videos can you please do a
shout out of the day
uh can you
do a shout out the day to sabine right
now she will freak i'll record it
tomorrow she loves you guys well sabine
sabine this is your shout out right
sabine you are so
amazingly
just
not just
hot externally yeah but hot
internal intellectual your mind is hot
too you are a sapiosexual's
dream
and you are
good
you know
it's a great compliment come on now you
got a wonderful mind you've got a great
character
you're named after cool you've got a
unique name that you're going to be
hearing a lot of people freak out about
the further we get into and sabine is a
great name yeah after rebels coming back
um
unless you don't like star wars and or
that character and unless they [ __ ] that
character up then yeah it's a terrible
time to become
the end of it but sabine generally a
good name this very very very simple
thank you for that very generous super
chat yeah
much love and uh and uh peace be with
you many blessings of our lord uh the
initiative i assume that that's what you
meant by spiritual i mean it could be
any spiritual practice but uh the
initiative just sending some more that's
where we're today on that one hey we are
in the spirit of forgiveness all right
i hope we're not offended
uh the initiative just sending more love
the last better console episode was
awesome have you seen winning time
succession i uh uh
i've seen like little snippets of
succession i'm not seeing any of it i
don't even know what it's about it is uh
what do you think it's about based on
the title i don't know i assume
something sexual
every time i hear about something i mean
sexual provocative or crime let's see
yeah yeah i mean it's yeah i mean i'm
sure there's some sexual stuff in there
it's it's about like a a
a dynasty a business dynasty it's like
this father figure and his you know kids
and whatnot who are all sort of
cutthroats and
sounds more like what it's titled
succession
the succession yeah uh but it's uh yeah
uh [ __ ] what's his name uh brian cox
and sarah snook sarah snook's a terrific
actress look her up thank you the
initiative i don't know what winning
time is though unfortunately we'll have
to look it up jacob neptune subscribed
years ago thank you for years of laughs
and creative thoughts into film and
entertainment industry looking forward
to more content and hopefully to
subscribe to you on patreon properly for
all the content to come thank you very
much that means a lot and don't worry
about that with patreon it means you
don't want to
be there then just know you're missing
out on many great exclusive videos
thousands of hours just so much great
stuff that you cannot watch because
you're not there
to experience it that is your fault not
ours fomo bro
don't worry about it jacob thank you for
the super chat
anywhere you are amicus
uh congratulations met you guys outside
sdcc 1999.
we took a pic and you were so kind and
young nine years old and i was like i
shouldn't be taking photos with nine
year olds but here i am they look like
future superstars these two
even after seeing marvel's panel and
meeting tom kennedy minutes before you
it was my favorite kenny oh cool my
favorite memory from sdcc oh thank you
so much that means a lot thank you yeah
we god we got to meet you we met a good
amount of people there but i remember
meeting you thank you dude
you're the only one i remember meaning
send us that picture everyone else dead
tag us in that pic everyone else's dad
does but you carlos lima
congratulations on hitting one million
subs love all of you guys you should do
more collaboration with this actually
collaboration
with each other love to see all you sexy
men together stay safe much love from
brooklyn new york oh my god a hundred
dollars thank you carlos thank you so
much he's trying to impress a lady right
now i know there you go here ain't gone
way to go on a millionaire
thanks carlos now that we've lampooned
your state uh hey
diaries
with the beautiful last name also your
brooklyn nine-nine reactions have been a
savior that means a lot cause barely
anyone watches us you are the one thank
you for watching greg and john
jaby have such infectious laughters
thanks y'all and yes let's get to two
million achara look at a fab
hell yeah agree with all of the above
sentiments thank you
dier diera diarrhea
i want to say it correctly thank you for
the comment thank you justinardo plays
v2 some some moment of silence but then
what realized today that maul isn't
doing anything ob cameo
darth maul you're just sitting around
they can't get off your lazy ass
stop chilling with the shadow collective
or whatever [ __ ] you guys are up to
during this period and go fight with
obi-wan
get off your lazy robo-legs
damn we've been in some instagram
stories today oh my golly we're gonna
have to repost them all get on that i'm
on it john you're good nasaki nisaki
if you were kevin feige
the way the mcu is coming together with
movies and disney plush shows what would
be the squad of the mcu midnight sons
teams also
how will they accomplish it or do you
mean like how will they introduce the
midnight suns if we are kevin feige if
you're camp feige
i think we'd have to work with the
current
avenue i would say wanda doctor strange
knight
daredevil
or is it too soon to include blade
yes okay and the wasp okay
the wasp is definitely a midnight sun
you need a tiny tiny person to go in
there yes definitely time person to go
up the devil's anus
time person to go memphis those buttons
yeah yeah
you gotta get that and explode you gotta
fist mephisto
on the butt yes that's a great team dude
it's a terrific team that's my midnight
sons my midnight sons is nicholas cage's
ghost rider diego luna's ghost rider no
it's not diego luke oh it's [ __ ]
gabrielle gabriel luna the other luna's
ghost rider and then uh nicholas cage's
spider noir
uh
hey both blades
and um who else is spooky uh
dormammu why not yeah i'm pure midnight
sun pattern as wall from the eternals
post credit scene yes patton uh yeah
quizzing
something close to that
forget to get something or not
i'm not gonna i knew like you're true
yes britney lane you're back
congratulations hitting 1 million subs
guys you deserve it all the love to you
guys thank you brittany
such a kind mother constantly donating
her college children's college fund to
our super chats thank you
sean tds do you plan to make a discord
how's your day you know we used to have
two discords one for youtube one for
patreon now we just have the one
and uh it's difficult to manage it so it
manages itself because uh you know y'all
are mostly adults and are capable of
doing that on your own if you can sign
up for patreon
either you've got a cool parent
or you're an adult so you know you guys
can regulate that
but yes if you would like to join in on
discord uh we have one through our uh
patreon page
also tony gill is another person i want
to thank for all the help he's given me
shooting sketches over the years yeah
dude he's helped him been our main
cameraman for a lot of things he's got
to shut them out reactions um
thanks dude congratulations on one
million guys from the uk shouts out
marie marie
thank you marie justice from justice for
marie where's marie
she got oscar's size from the channel so
i should never gain back my sake also
congrats on 1 million guys i've been a
fan since you guys said iraq to
supernatural season one on patreon i'm
still really into that show i love
supernatural really really really into
that [ __ ] just began season 10 for those
of you not playing along and i [ __ ]
love that show yeah love it
[Music]
it it's been a wild ride man it's been a
very wild ride but hey you've got years
worth of content backlogged to theirs
i hope you have fun
josh
congrats been watching your channel for
five years random question better series
last airbender or legend of korra i
think there are things legend akora
definitely does better sometimes
visually um like honestly the first five
episodes of legend of korra i was like
oh [ __ ] this might take the cake
for a better series i'm only on season
three of legend of korra right now uh
but i would confidently say avatar is a
much better composed story for sure that
that legend of korra
i'm just not as into the characters as i
am like the story and plot in the world
is still really cool but the characters
are just much more definitive
and um like i have no nostalgia for last
airbender because i only just watched
him in the last year
and uh but i would definitely say like
no those characters are clear cut and
and the arcs are really strong
so i'm i'm more in but then i haven't
wrapped up legend of korra yet but so
far i'm like nah it seems like it's
gonna be pretty obvious that's gonna be
that um holy [ __ ] there is as good as
the movie no definitely not ddk this is
a great question because i'm probably
gonna be going to this theater more
often now oh yeah because uh we're only
gonna be like how far is it from there
like 10 minutes less than that probably
yeah um
uh dk you all rocked you ever watching
40x of the north hollywood regal theater
epic for for action films thank you for
everything congrats we're only going to
be like 10 minutes away from there so
that would probably go there that or
universal uh amc or the uh
cold the the noho cinemark as well oh
there's another host cinemark this is
the one on coldwater that we go to oh
yeah yeah yeah
but uh uh no it's not a good center mark
it's not as good as this
it's like the same thing with amc
there's like some great amc theaters and
there's like oh like oh that's a shitty
amc yeah yeah they did not have a good a
this is terrible but most of the cinema
the sunrise we go to are the ones we
dropped like 40 minutes to go to and
then those are the primo ones yeah this
one just got remodeled for the first
time in decades
yeah yeah but dk also uh
back in the day when we were doing a
different schedule obviously and and
different work that was
the regal there was one of my go-to
theaters when we had to do a movie
review and i wanted to catch like a
matinee like often they would have you
know some of the best showings so uh you
got arcades in the in the lobby i'm down
i'm down with the regal it's a good
theater i like it
uh pranav bot congratulations greg and
john for 1 million so thank you so much
1 million submarine sandwiches we have
eaten today that's great i want more of
them ian immoral
hey
it's my favorite reactor and three dudes
jokes apart love y'all
i guess that was a joke for a char
congrats on one million yes so let her
know just clip this inside thank you
thank you i'm glad us two dudes could at
least be here to you know field that for
you have we reached the top yet we're so
close
i found you last year i found bts last
year found your old bts reaction videos
and stuck around oh my god this is
actually such a relief congratulations
on 1 million bts come back on 6 10. okay
what's what's a relief about this
is sometimes you do [ __ ] on here
it's like i know people who like really
utilize the amber herd johnny depp [ __ ]
there are people who really like milk
that right and did a lot of videos on
that sure what and then they're like
and then they were like but i don't know
if the people who sub to this are going
to want to check out this other stuff
that i really regularly do
and so like what we did some bts videos
but we were like ass isn't really what
we wanted to do though anymore
and so to know that like eventually we
had some people who transitioned into
watching the other stuff that we
regularly do it's like oh they got that
pad down yeah
yeah that actually found out yeah good
to know though i mean good to know that
is good to know thank you you know amid
this busy array of things we have to do
each day and week i i i fantasize about
coming back to music video stuff for
patreon so i'll keep an eye on that bts
comeback
uh the initiative good night fellas good
night thanks buddy we'll be saying good
night soon jax facts hey jaby
love you so much subscribe since thor
love and thunder reaction congrats on
two million subs hopefully see you at
three
hi john
this i am screenshotting as the most
random and lovely weird comment in our
super chats today and your paddington
slash maybe pattinson avatar is great
divazio
congrats on the one million subs i was
so surprised to find out greg and i
share the same birthday oh yeah my
birthday with you guys
virgos for life man that's right dog all
right we're at the top we are so close
to the top great
oh man it's so deceiving
get that pretty face from the back and
place her in the middle well we did
batman
seeing her we
kicked her out of the room she is out in
the world now so i hope you got all your
achara time in earlier tonight i have
the biggest crush on achara
that's all bye
in a row
so too bad she wasn't here to see it ah
nissa
nissa we finally met so
it's midnight windows open oh don't
shout josh anisa
congrats i'm so proud of y'all and
everything y'all have accomplished since
being here from the beginning to now
saying thank you isn't enough i love you
guys so much and again so proud see you
soon we met anissa in person just a
couple weeks ago she's been one of our
longest followers and she's also been
just a great friend overall absolutely
and then uh yeah we hung out with her in
santa monica
a couple weeks ago and uh had a
fantastic time with her she's such a gem
in real life thank you anisa that's
right you're the best denise so you're
the freaking best
simon aylett your reactions when seeing
the train scene on invincible congrats
guys from the uk thank you is it a good
scene
yeah yeah watching vince ball shows
phenomenal
with mark wahlberg where he wants to
join the field yeah the paramount play
you know
movie directed by tom that's right i
love it
let's do it no i know that one's called
like infinite or something oh okay you
want to talk about infinite do you want
to talk about the mark wahlberg anton
fuqua movie that like no one watched i
clearly don't infinite i think it's
called infinite maybe this sounds
vaguely invisible is the football movie
infinite it's like the action movie
it came out recently and it flopped
right
yeah like hard like yeah no i think
that's why i know what it is yeah yeah
yeah yeah jeremy is like a disaster of a
flop
i don't know i think you got a mandela
effect i don't think this movie ever
existed jeremy cole been watching since
2014 just about to start high school
and now i'm 22 and in the army in the
middle east dealing with a-holes i've
never heard anyone do this is that what
journey
uh your guys videos have lifted my
spirits on a lot of bad days in the last
eight months thank you usa oh my god
damn thank you for your service i mean
that means a lot to know that you're
watching from way out there and i'm glad
that that we're able to keep you we
feeling good we help the army feel
better we're like the uso you know when
they send like comedians to go perform
for the army exactly that's what we are
for the youtube space
we help phil avoid to distract we're
doing a service from the petty problems
in the middle east you know the minor
problems in the middle east these these
these these annoyances first world
issues that they're having these peeves
we helped distract from the boredom out
there so thank you is everyone walking
around like ah i wish there was
something to do here thank you for your
support thank you jeremy thank you man
hey get home get back safe please and
then we got some stickers yeah let's uh
let's refresh the oh we got this are
there people still in the chat it's
midnight it's time to play we're
checking to see if i imagine there's
like 200 people in the chat there's 792
people still in the chat am i right 820
concurrent viewers what that's insane i
don't know 635
627 that makes more sense all right
there we go there we go that tracks that
tracks all right let's see thank you
guys for everyone's been jumping in here
captain wreck
loom jenny
and my voice is too scratched to do it
it's all about them i can't do it right
now wow normally i can always do it i
know it's like
[Music]
[Music]
constantly sounding
drunk
without
being drunk without my
super pint
it's
mega pine
is it is it even though you don't
remember and you needed to have it read
to you from your own testing
uh hey james holy crap what a big one
thank you oh thank you y'all are good
people you're good peoples found you
through screen junkies and the schmoes
and schmo down
i was on screen junkies and schmoes i
was around the schmoe down
and i was there when the schmoes came
over
do you worry
how are you i was nervous to meet them
yeah now i'm like where are you guys now
and now you're nervous to pick up the
phone every time they call yeah i call
him small penis ellis
yeah i call him [ __ ] off harloff
yes
thank you for such a great as a
contribution thank you buddy i
appreciate it man green girl 315. love
you guys i love you more congrats no
[ __ ] carasa you been watching since
first season of stranger things wow we
only started the third and i've been
she's watching the upside down i've been
becoming a youtube reaction and nerd
theory junkie because of you and new
rock stars you rock you rock we have no
reason we should have no inspiration in
your nerd dude if we rock that means
we're almost like rock stars
we're the new new rock stars
yeah we're like when a show's over and
they decide to keep it going
with a new cast but they haven't
canceled it so it's just like
okay
why did you call this something
different at least jeez package it up
like it's a spin-off or something god
jc kill pack that's a cool ass name
congrats guys been watching for years
glad to see that you all finally hit 1
million much love thank you very much jc
kill pack you're a sexy son of a [ __ ]
live pack bronson plays
hello
you already said that you can react to
our spider-man short film on youtube so
i sent the link on both y'all's
instagrams thank you yeah
if we have time we'll consider it right
now take a look worst case was shared on
the community page at least at least
if the trio our reaction videos believe
it or not usually take up to like an
hour and a half to two hours to put
together
and you can tell when they have not
taken that it may look like we just
turned on the camera
and nothing else happened but actually
there's a lot that goes into a lot of
this stuff uh
efreo congrats guys you gave me a
terrible shout out seven years ago on
april fool's day and i still reference
it to this day you got to send that to
me excited to see your growth congrats
again on
and good
god keep up the god work thank you we
will keep up the god thank you
we will
nominate
espirito
and uh let's check in the check and see
last time we got this we got to honor
everyone who contributed honor
everything and we're gonna see who's in
this the regular chat for a little bit
andy180 wants us to rank all the
spiderman suits
oh my god uh that's easy
let's do it
spiderman
two photo maguire good one andrew
garfield's
oh yeah
from tasm too
yeah yeah
that might be my favorite one it's
pretty great it has them too as much as
that movie doesn't get the love it does
have a great i think that's my favorite
one
it is a great suit it's a great suit i
would actually you know what
i would also elevate and this might be a
hot take but i love the tobey maguire
early stage wrestling spider-man outfit
with the
balaclava umbrella you know i like a
night monkey but i also love that one my
mom messaged me congratulations on one
million subscribers ah and i said i only
did it to escape the pain that you
inflicted on me when i was a child mom
do you love me am i enough for you to
help mom
what are you now saying you're proud of
me mom are you happy now
what did you watch
all righty we did it all yeah we got you
we did it all
all righty we got slime and aylett we
got jeremy cole yeah we did it we're
using this ben anderson thank you for
the stickers people look at that oh
spinning around in a little chair i love
it yash sharma it says
get out
or something
out a dd
get
get get gup
get gupp it's less hazardous if i zoom
in now get get a gup
get
get gum you get good
get good get good thank you
gud
that's what it looks like get get good
it's like a little hippo shouting i love
it yeah
who what else do we got maybe they
shouldn't put the words behind the
[ __ ] hip
remember maybe i should find a way to
make these like bigger
because i've blown these up quite a bit
thank you matt mccomas
who is waving at us and rolling up his
sleeves it looks like nice i love it uh
hey ooh
that's like a whole stack of things
oh there's a little guy with sunglasses
right has he got his arms folded is he
just downloading tons of info into his
brain
yah sharma thank you so much we've made
it we thank you guys we are here let's
go back to the regular chat let's blow
everything down
people are saying
let's get back
who who are the people who are here at
midnight when we're so used to doing
this from eleven to three
who is in the afternoon who are the true
real rejects after dark yeah let's see
who's here
let's do that all right let's go let's
hit this little bottom best reaction out
there thank you
i don't know how long the stream is
it started
at 8 30. when did it start it started
the camera quality is not bad
it's better than what we normally have
common sense jamie eilando
actually can't watch any series without
watching
yeah immediately hey
the camera quality is better than it
normally is yeah
see the colors look a little yellow
still on the stream well it's because
it's on night mode
oh okay let me turn off the night mode
sorry we've had so many streaming issues
so this is just something that we really
want to hello there jamie as long as it
looks how you turn off the night mode uh
actually it might be in your
little curtain thing
uh
you know what john shut up
shut up you don't you you never know
what you're talking about i just found
it jamie ilano i actually can't watch
any series without watching you guys
react immediately after i have a few
guys that come back to but you guys are
always looking for that
oh that does look pretty decent that
actually looks like smooth yeah oh my
god
david gandy david gaming you saved the
doors off all right let's see what's in
the chat there's no super chats anymore
we turn them off we're done we'll turn
them off an hour ago we finally got it
done
we're done
thank you
why don't you guys tell us we're gonna
be here just for a couple more minutes
why don't you guys tell us where you're
uh
where you're uh where you're all from
can you listen listen to us in the chat
we got 600 people in the chat right now
we've been alive for a long time so i
just want to see who's in the chat
tell us what where you reside from
yes idaho someone wants india to play
california dreaming
indio everyone's from india indio hey no
spoilers what'd you think of episode 4
of stranger things oh that might be the
one of the best episodes of the season
i was putting the thumbnail together for
it today 3m in michigan and i started
interior yes
just going through the footage of like
what's the right image to use for the
thumbnail
and i just found myself watching a scene
you guys probably know what seed
watching a scene and i just started
tearing up again like i didn't finish
this thumbnail
dude that episode i think is my that one
followed by the finale or the mid season
finale is probably my second favorite if
a show doesn't have your reaction i
won't watch you guys that means a lot
that's good you have a narrow scope of
things you're allowed to watch then
uh happy million thank you calpak
uh we got 3 a.m in michigan what'd it do
brian mchenry in philadelphia watching
from my rack wow whoa
amara world hells yeah thank you for
joining l.a chino hills you're not too
far from us man
since ryan right thank you new brunswick
canada orlando florida louisiana chris
jones you can put the chat on the stream
so people know right from cali living in
oregon
we'll just turn our heads so we can see
it
yeah
zero expand it
you got this john you can figure
everything out up again
i'll blow it up again
it's 5 p.m there oh dang where in iraq
who said that
i wanted to invite tomorrow morrison to
do a special dance for you guys the one
he did at star wars celebration oh i
would have wanted to do pennsylvania did
he do like a haka uh hello from south
dakota los angeles peter d'armanian
what's up pennsylvania
driving home from a punjabi wedding in
dallas nice good to see you pasadena
california we got a lot of california
folks yeah i like it out there was an
area we were thinking of moving to at
one point puerto rico long long island
island how do you like it when i was
[ __ ] californians coming here yeah
long island one of your [ __ ] voices
long island iced tea
the season finale was great we literally
shot the season finale
and then um when we were wrapping up the
review we were like oh we're two
subscribers away from a million we
should probably do a live stream
so like three hours went by and we were
like whoa we're close to a million
what's going on here
another cat has entered the stream hello
copper
philippines pinoy pride thank you
thank you so much for being here it's 5
p.m in australia well good for you guys
lucky you you're a reasonable hour
kolkata india we got a lot of people
from different parts of the world
new zealand idaho over here
haven't uh we haven't moved anything
over to the new house yet olivia has
dude it's 12 17 p.m here too but we have
uh we're we're going to be moving this
week so we have to we fortunately got
two
screeners for miss marvel which is very
helpful at a time when you have to move
oh yeah so it's gonna be weird when you
see videos the new place and then
suddenly miss marvel comes out and you
have videos of us here
so uh that
and then two episodes of that and uh we
got two of the boys as well which
haven't seen yet we just want to get
stranger things knocked out
dude and then uh we got obi-wan this
week so it's going to be a weird week
because i have to move in but i also
want to get the shows up too that's
right mayank gulati are you related to
jatin
jateen
our editor actually my onc we're going
to be watching jurassic world dominion
in d-box d-box
encourage you to do the same thing i
like d-box i know i don't like fallen
kingdom i like the experience of d-box
so we want to do it again
uh hey taiwan what's up karen taiwan
liverpool are vinsanity are you really
watching from area 51 you you better be
like i want you like if no because you
could be like the guard in a little
shack just like waiting to drive up to
the top of the hill in case anyone gets
too close and what do you do when nine
times out of ten that doesn't happen
you're watching on yeah i hope so that's
what i want baltimore maryland baltimore
germany man scotland this is crazy john
waters sure blows my mind still blows my
mind it's 12 18 here too austin chino
let's do it sri lanka damn
this really is mind-blowing it's like to
to see all these people oxnard
california oxnard california the beaches
in oxnard are my um uh a lot it was last
year this year
uh for one of our anniversaries olivia
and i we went to um oxnard california
one of the beaches and we had a really
good deal for an airbnb that was right
uh like a
like a townhouse or just a no it wasn't
like a a house house but uh
yeah to rent a townhouse that was like a
30 second walk from the beach and i love
oxnard california it's only about an
hour from where we are right now and i i
love oxnard california i really really
do it's very nice you're metal derek
woodward you're so metal shout out from
gilroy california y'all never been to
gilroy vape nation whoa what's koi doing
for you guys seeing a million he's drunk
and with a lady he's like uh does it
mean i could get paid more now yeah
so uh guys
i mean to talk about my rate
i see you doing a lot of brand videos
yeah i'm doing that to pay for the rig
that's right my dude episode three
reaction dylan goes up tomorrow for
stranger things
estonia rauno
that's cool how are things in estonia
we'll probably upload episode three and
four tomorrow yeah i think what people
are waiting for is to get the force so
episode four and it's sunday so i'm like
why don't we just do three people on
sunday yeah then one a day for the rest
of them russia is watching you in a good
way oh i hope you're doing all right out
there cinema nerd the world is messed up
but we're glad to have you with us
thanks for being here i hope things are
uh are okay where you are uh
andy uh smallville
humphrey brown i like it a lot
all right guys look you're our last
people we're going to be with today what
are we at oh man we grew up in viewers
or 658 hey what do you know just reading
off where people are from we'll grow
your viewers we got hotlanta ga in the
building we got sunday 9 19 a.m we got
elkhart indiana ooh you're right by
hawkins
uh koi's yes coy is drunken and with the
lady thank you for all the congrats from
the philippines more philippines more
dominican republic indonesia indonesia
indonesia was the first thing to start
growing this channel with the raid
that's when things really started to
take off so the bay area i'm very much
uh very much uh my heart is with
with the raid uh with ray with uh with
raiding people with uh indonesia
dude chicago what's up 12 221am we
acknowledge you chicago that's a very
kind word words chelsea and yeah people
love john's psych reactions on patreon
very much though the amount of
enthusiasm i see for comments and john's
reactions makes me go [ __ ] maybe i
should watch the show sometime from
orange county thank you chelsea thrilled
for you never been to sannapolis
westlake no i have been there in fact i
went when it opened i think if i'm
thinking of the right place i don't have
wanna
thank you being here from chicago at two
in the morning oh yeah but yeah all
right guys
uh i gotta prep the video i gotta finish
some thumbnails and prep the videos
let's take about 30 minutes each
for the final stages of there's the
uploading and prepping a whole video
yeah and i got i'm gonna do it for three
and four stranger things uh right now
it's midnight at 12 20.
i'm gonna eat some food and finally get
some sleep yeah and we're going to start
packing tomorrow so let's get moving
this week but
um
dominican republic awesome uh karina
thank you
all right guys we uh we are considering
reacting
when we have time we are considering it
heroes reforged what's up buddy thank
you
thank you
what's up team what's up adam good to
see you um thank you so much for
watching your videos lately they're
great i think heroes are forged can be
like the biggest needs
they need to be at a million i mean
their knowledge and and uh the quality
of their stuff is so phenomenal i mean
that sincerely
um all right we'll get we'll get a char
back but thank you guys for being here
and uh thank you for again for helping
us hit a million subscribers
it means a lot to to to be on this path
and uh
yeah you know if we i actually
plan with john i'm like hey i think we
might hit it tomorrow
and i told my whole game plan about like
11 30 let's meet up and probably end by
two and then when we were done with
stranger things i was like oh we might
hit it happen we might hit it in like 20
minutes
that tends to happen so yeah with a plan
like that then all of a sudden things
change yeah like oh we gotta go it's
time yeah but thank you guys uh yeah we
gotta wrap this up because i gotta get
to some some of the other work but uh
thanks it means a lot to have you here
and thanks for making this special
we will talk with you guys soon cheers
this is a really really special one
today thank you thank you guys
absolutely
signing off you stay sexy you stay
classy and we'll see you at two minutes
i haven't waited in a while but we gotta
look at those guns look at the gun show
no no i see the lack of ball here
what is wrong with your balls you know
when you hang out with philip molina you
just go i'm disgusting
that's where i got my body dysmorphia
come away from hanging out
with myself i thought i was hot [ __ ]
until i hung with phil molina
i just stared myself in the mirror when
i got home and i was like you are
pathetic you are ugly
you will never be philip molina
all right guys
on that note
you are all beautiful
we'll see you next time cheers
and
bye bye